Elon Musk has filed his lawsuit against
Media Matters and he says it is
thermonuclear everybody is now joining
the war against the censorship
industrial complex that's what they're
calling it a group of activists and
political personalities who have been
filing false takedowns and waging the
cancel cancel culture war against so
many of us and and now the war is on
Babylon B announced they be pledging
$250,000 into ads on X I immediately got
on Twitter and announced we would be
joining The Babylon be's efforts with a
$250,000 ad campaign of our own and many
others also joined in Andrew Tate
pledged $1 million per month so many
people are joining the fry and Chris
pavlovski the CEO of Rumble announced
the Cavalry is coming and they too will
be assisting in the in the war against
the censorship Industrial complex we
have the court filing it is it is up and
we're going to go through it and talk
about why it's so serious they are
trying to destroy X because Elon Musk
will not and in my opinion I think this
is fair to say he will not give the
government the back doors they want
Twitter did Twitter bent the knee now
all of these fascists are coming out
saying if you don't give the government
their secret police access they will
destroy you so we're fighting back in
other news Javier mle has won in
Argentina this guy is described as
libertarian anarcho capitalist far right
he's endorsed by Trump bolsonaro and
naib melli so naturally everyone is
super excited especially when you look
at videos of him ripping down a whole
bunch of names of government departments
and screaming AA or out when he's
ripping them down the people of
Argentina are sick and tired of the woke
nonsense and so they said let's roll
baby we got a lot of fun stuff to talk
about Donald Trump is actually winning
among 18 to 39 year I'm sorry 18 to 34
year olds so there is a lot of big news
plus this one's pretty crazy a new
documentary coming out that is I I
believe it might already be out about
derck chovin and George Floyd suggests
the FBI altered the autopsy report of
George Floyd and that the original
report did not mention in any way
asfixiation chovin says it was a sham
trial just as the Supreme Court refuses
to take up his appeal so we'll talk
about all that before we get started my
friends head over to cast brew.com and
buy the best coffee you've ever had our
limited edition rise with Roberto Jr is
going fast and it will not exist once
this run is done we made this for
Halloween it is mocking our dead mascot
Roberto Jr we love him but still we have
fun and it shows his little rooster foot
erupting from the earth as a zombie get
rise today zombie blend we also have
everyone's favorite rise with Roberto Jr
and Appalachian kns I'll tell you right
now if you go to the if you go to the
cast Brew Coffee Twitter account there
is a buy one get one code available for
black available for Black Friday
and more importantly when you support
cast Brew you are supporting our efforts
at setting up physical locations and I
know I've been talking about it all year
sooner or later you know sooner or later
like all the professional equipment is
coming in the renovations are being done
it exists it's in Martinsburg West
Virginia we will have that location up
and ready for physical Hangouts but also
don't forget to go to timcast.net
go up Monday through Thursday at at 1:
p.m. we're going to have an awesome one
up for you tonight as well as join our
Discord server smash that like button
share the show with all your friends
joining us tonight to talk about this
and so much more is Danny polishuck yo
how's it going who are you what are you
doing I a comedian I am a co-host of the
boys cast with Ryan long who a lot of
people probably know and I also host on
Tuesday nights a Callin show I'm trying
to bring Colin shows back it's called
Low value mail m a i l and again I'm a
standup comedian so everybody in the
chat as soon as they saw that you were
in like and I'm the guy who makes lists
so people know me as that guy they were
like oh this is going to be the funniest
episode ever cuz Danny's here he's so
funny and I was like man pressure's on
all right good luck sir we got Phil
hanging out hello everybody my name is
Phil abony I'm a very failed musician
the lead singer of All That Remains uh
I'm an anti-communist and a
counterrevolutionary hi I'm Ian crosson
what's happening dude and I have
presents for Ian okay I'd like to hand
you this one first and you can show it
show it to the camera nice this is the
first one's a t-shirt I got one for Luke
as well and it's from the uh Flight 93
Memorial hey Flight 93 we I went we went
to the memorial memorial couple weekends
ago and we were able to pick up some
stuff that I thought would be
interesting for Ian so uh I also have
this for you this is a book I would like
you to read like you can hold up this is
a book the 911 Commission report that's
a big book oh this is valuable and then
of course these we got in the summer and
I just forgot to give them to Ian this
is a crystal from Tijuana that was
charged in the ocean by Luc Kowski
charged that means he dipped it in the
water and he Char does he do like a
spell I I guess
conly all I know is Luke took off his
shirt jumped in the water and said now
the crystal has been charged and that we
were supposed to give it to Ian and I
don't know what that means but I guess
all of the hippie people know exactly
what it means they're probably like oh
wow good for
Ian structural lce you feel it yeah do
you feel that it's charged I think so it
could be psychosomatic I don't know but
it feels like the other Crystal that
Luke gave me that was charged is it warm
or is it more like a vibration it's like
warm actually conducts uh and then
here's a little bag his back pocket with
mini mushrooms it is full of can you see
glass these are not for eating like
apparently they're little glass
mushrooms he those he do thank you man
let's roll baby hurry up I was someone
gives you a bag of random mushrooms in
movies you just eat them and see what
happens not the glass ones I told me
before the show I was like I got you
presents but the immediate assumption is
going to be some kind of gag I'm like no
actually got you gifts like when we were
out we just never gave them to you
they're made of different things there's
wood this is glass this one is uh
normally we get Ian soap but like goat
milk soap you know like really fancy
stuff with none of the weird Shen hooked
it up last week so got soap for weeks
soap for months right on all right we
got Serge press the butt yeah I'm just
watching I get all these gifts seeing
the joy in his eyes is a great thing yes
mushro anyways uh let's get started to
all right here's the first story from
the New York Post Elon musk's X follows
through with thermonuclear lawsuit
against Media Matters messaging platform
acts on Monday sued Media Matters
Watchdog group uh sued Media Watch Dog
group Media Matters alleging the
organization defamed the platform after
it published a report said ads for Major
Brands had appeared next to uh next to
posts touting Nazism now here's where it
gets uh uh really fascinating I'll tell
you I'll break it down for you very
simply what Elon Musk is saying as well
as several employees publicly stating
this what Media Matters for America dead
to understand what Media Matters is
there is a series of democrat and
government aligned groups that engage in
lawfare and cancel culture to destroy
people who believe in Liberty among one
thing and those who are conservative and
so what they're saying they're alleging
what Media Matters did and this is
really fascinating Media Matters created
new accounts or accessed accounts that
had been around for just 30 days to
bypass certain restrictions they then
intentionally followed a a handful of
Nazi accounts and a handful of
Advertiser accounts to to create a
timeline where their posts existed next
to each other that's pretty amazing
isn't it yeah so if you choose if I
choose to follow Phil and choose to
follow Danny and then I get a post from
Phil and a post from Danny I go oh why
why is this post from this offensive
comedian appearing next to my wholesome
have you met music it's it's like
actually going to be like because you
chose for it to because you wanted it
this is a free speech platform we're
we're allowing the point is we're
allowing you to do that so we uh we have
the document here you got it yeah so the
document is up we have it right here
United States district court for the
Northern District of Texas Fort Worth
Division excp and NADA Corporation
versus Media Matters for America they
say defendant Media Matters for America
is a self-proclaimed media Watchdog that
decided it would not let the truth get
in the way of a story it wanted to
publish about excort looking to portray
X's social networking platform as being
dominated by white nationalists and
anti-semitic conspiracy theories Media
Matters knowingly and maliciously
manufactured side-by-side images
depicting advertisers post on excorp
social media platforms besides Neo-Nazi
and white nationalist Fringe content and
then portrayed these manufact Ed images
as if they were
typical as if they were what typical X
users experienced in the platform Media
Matters designed both these images and
it's resulting media strategy to drive
advertisers from the platform and
Destroy excorp and as of right now this
is a big deal we got Apple IBM Lionsgate
Disney Comcast nbcu Paramount Warner
Brothers Discovery and other firms have
paused their marketing this is a massive
hit to X's Revenue based on lies they
going to say plaintiff excorp operates
the ex social media platform with over
500 million active monthly users
facilitates free expression open
discourse etc etc we get it we get it so
now we're hearing I think it's the AG
out of Missouri is investigating fraud
because it's both civil and criminal
fraud at this point and I got to be
honest I think any reasonable person who
looks at what Media Matters does will
conclude it is it is a it is a it's
fraud yeah when when an organization
lies intentionally and then you uses
those lies to engage in torous
interference now you've got you're going
Beyond just a civil civil case it's
criminal yeah I mean Apple alone is I
think they said Apple alone spends a
$100 million a year I don't know what
the grand total of all these companies
is but that's some serious
damage Barry Media Matters I mean that I
don't know what kind of uh you know
margin they make but or what kind of
well they're like a nonprofit yeah it's
a nonprofit it's I think El might just
own them after this he's going to do the
same it's a nonprofit you don't own them
it's just they're going to there's not
much you can do evil people do evil
things and even if they're on the hook
to El on musk for substantial sums of
money they keep doing what they're doing
I mean evil exists man well I mean if
there is Criminal prosecution that might
actually change Behavior because then
that'll turn into uh you know there
could be prosecution for for criminal
put them in jail or something sure I
don't think there would be for there's
attempts there's there Tim mentioned the
uh Missouri case but also the uh owner
of Rumble was just tweeting I don't know
where it went to uh was just tweeting
that trying to get the attention of Jim
Jordan and and Congress so I don't know
yeah I don't know what protections a
nonprofit has against stuff like this I
think the floodgates are are busting
open I don't think that many people
really buy this stuff anymore because
it's not it's not just that yeah the uh
uh I agree with you but if if uh the
Republicans look into the taken down of
parlor now it's big yeah yeah we're
talking about the government colluding
with private organizations to shut down
businesses to censor speech this goes
well beyond just someone got banned on
Twitter yeah I mean parlor was clearly
an effort to to shut down any possible
uh you know counternarrative to what was
being put on Twitter when before you
know after after January 6th it was
clear I mean Amazon shut their servers
down there was all kinds of push from
the government to to shut them down I
don't know I don't remember the details
but yeah they had their servers like
pulled basically you know I I don't
think that that's there's not a whole
lot of question as to whether or not
that happened I don't hear people saying
No this didn't happen or whatever um you
know so it pretty clearly I'm curious
how long these these companies are going
to CU I'm sure Twitter has provided them
with a report they did right saying like
hey here's our like backend data just
saying like hey this is totally
misrepresented they break it down I mean
this is actually quite hilarious what
but what they're arguing in the lawsuit
is that Media Matters exclusively
followed a small subset of users
consisting entirely of accounts in one
of two categories those known to produce
extreme Fringe content and accounts
owned by X's bigname advertisers the end
result was a feed Precision designed by
medium matters for a single purpose to
produce side bys side ad content
placements that it could screenshot in
an effort to alienate advertisers yo
they followed crazy guy followed apple
and then went oh no the posts are
appearing next to each other but that's
quite literally you choosing yeah that's
I mean the question is how long all
these companies kind of keep up with
because they've done this before didn't
they recently do this exact same thing
where all these advertisers paused their
I don't remember what the last but like
someone did something similar they go
hey you know what's going on and all
these or like something Elon tweeted and
then everybody paused and then they come
back and they're like I I'm GNA I
there's serious damages like a week of
no ads that I mean that's significant D
huge money I got elon's play for you I
said this during the YouTube ad
apocalypse and I'm going to say it now
and I hope Elon here's it here's what
you do buddy let's play a
game IBM Apple insert company nbcu they
want to go to war with you over
something that is obviously and
knowingly false I want to I want
everyone to understand this you think
Apple doesn't know this is fake yeah
there's no way their marketing people
are like Oh Heaven me I can't believe
this happening no they know exactly what
it is it's curated and it's fake so
here's what you do Elon advertise
against them and what I would say is
whatever amount of money you'd spend in
marketing that you pull off the table we
will cost you tenfold in negative press
yeah good luck the way I the way I
viewed it with you with YouTube was when
you know big company X announces they're
pulling up the platform I'd immediately
offer a premium deal to their main
competition Apple wants to jump off the
platform i' go to Microsoft and say
we'll give you the double double the
access for half the cost Microsoft then
goes oh oh boy now we're getting a
premium deal and here's what you do make
the ads and Sal Apple now Apple's got to
contend with massive multi-million
dollar marketing against them because
they chose to play with the live yeah th
this is probably just like the most like
basic cya for them and they'll just you
know they they'll be back I imagine
they'll all be back in short order
what's cya cover your ass they just go
hey like someone said something and they
go we they play it the most safest
possible but you said a moment ago like
you know no one's really falling for it
anymore I don't think they're falling
for it either and I don't think they're
concerned I think they're part no I
meant like the regular people cuz the
thing with Media Matters I don't exactly
know their thing but like like the
biggest competition to mainstream media
right now is X like if I turn on CNN or
Fox right now or MSNBC like I'm just
watching what I saw on Twitter
yesterday yeah YouTube YouTube and andx
I would say YouTube's like the ultimate
although YouTube's kind of mainstream
thing Twitter has the real citizen
journalism though where like you know
something happen and there's just a guy
like there who's just even YouTube is is
a day late because everyone that's
talking about you know what's going on
if they're making videos yeah it takes
at least a few hours to produce it
unless you're doing like live stream
stuff and that stuff is done on X
nowadays people are if you want to look
for the most recent news it's going to
be on X always been that way right I'm
on the ground at Occupy Wall Street the
video is instantly up on Twitter Youtube
was like it doesn't really work that way
yeah it's it's just a slightly different
way that people injust that that content
there's production value like I mean
even even low low you know people that
Pride themselves on low production value
or you know looking like it's DIY and
stuff there's some production value
whether it be editing or stuff like that
so you can't get it up as fast as you
can on YouTube I mean like if there's
like a giant car AC like car crash or
something it's just someone whips out
their phone and they go this is you know
crazy and then that's that that's where
you're going to see it first before
anywhere so and you know you're not
going to get banned off X for uploading
it whereas on YouTube it's like did you
vet this better if you're going to say
this is real by posting it then you
better vet this even if even if you did
vet it even if it is real they'll just
they'll still just kick you off or
whatever demon it depends certain
certain things yeah but it's like it's
not it's not like The Proving Ground is
kind of X it's like the testing ground
for data fake stuff goes up real stuff
goes up and then we decide what's real
and then we put that on YouTube Here's
the wild here's the wild thing if Jack
dorsy Still owned X Twitter you would be
banned for criticizing Hamas not even
I'm I I I think it is a very very strong
likelihood that you know what was it
Facebook's rules said that you were
allowed to praise Nazis so long as they
were fighting in Russia yeah right so
it's like I'm pretty sure that uh you I
mean the crazy thing right now is uh
Michael Rapaport if you saw on Instagram
if you go to follow him on Instagram
right now it gives you the warning that
says this account posts um like
controversial thing no not it's like
fake and
misleading got as soon as he said he'd
vote for Trump they got him isn't that
crazy someone sent that to me I go I
couldn't believe it I had to see for
myself and it literally says if you go
follow Michael rap we pull that up we'll
pull that up I have it I took a
screenshot of him on my phone and uh cuz
I'm like rap aore you think that guy's
been orange man bad for but he just came
out and said he's he's considering
voting for trump it says this this are
you sure you want to follow Michael
Rapaport this account has repeatedly
posted false information that was
reviewed by independent fact cheers or
went
against this is why they need to destroy
X Elon Musk shattered a large portion of
their narrative control that's what I'm
saying yeah so some argue a lot people
on the left argue that if uh if Jack
dorsy on the platform you would not be
able to criticize Israel I I I think
it's the other way around I mean I I got
kicked off Instagram recently on October
8th is when I started but I I think it
Donald Trump being the biggest issue for
them Michael Rapaport makes a video
where he like big dick Donald Trump I'm
going to vote for him I'm considering it
and then it's like and it's funny cuz he
kind of sounds like a high-pitch version
of trump and and now they're putting a a
flag on his account crazy cuz he's like
been the most just like every allowable
opinion orange man bad all that stuff
forever and then the moment he veers off
of the acceptable kind of stuff Gone
Gone let's carry this on we got this
tweet from Chris pavlovski he says X is
not alone I also confirmed that Media
Matters has purposely misrepresented
Rumble their dishonesty warrants an
immediate investigation at the highest
levels and he says hint speaker Johnson
and Jim Jordan and I'll bring the
receipts here's my statement he says
Media Matters is threatened by rumble's
mission to protect a free and open
internet so the reaction is to deceive
the public and scare advertisers for
example on March 14th Media Matters
claimed that advertisements of for
Netflix which were appearing on Rumble
had been placed on videos that violated
our content policies however according
to Google analytics the week before
before publication of that Media Matters
article there had been zero page views
of that video this means that the Media
Matters activist who took the
screenshots was the first human being to
actually view the Netflix ad on the
video in question though their story
left the false impression that it was a
widespread problem the same is true for
most of the videos seted by Media
Matters all of which were removed from
Rumble as soon as we were made aware of
them it's clear that Media Matters
intends to mislead and deceive about
advertisements on Rumble in order to
hamper free speech and harm law iding
employers who only want to advertise
their product and services yo it's
torous interference you there's no
reason why you you can't just say you
know Chris and El they're trying to cost
you money and damage your business take
it to the the the monetary uh issue
right here prove damages let Media
Matters outright admit that they're
doing this and then show it to a judge
do we know who funds them uh it's it
well probably George Soros yeah that
would be no I think that's actually
easily confirmed that was a big article
that people were sharing but it's it's a
nonprofit that receives a bunch of
donations he says Media Matters doesn't
do anything for free so who is funding
this outrageous targeting activity who
is paying for them to Target free speech
and and why are they afraid of free
expression online speaker Johnson rep
Jordan it's time for Congress to ask
hard questions Elon Musk respond saying
they have a long track record of evil
Deeds an investigation is badly needed I
will tell you this right now I will
place a large sum of money I mean this
figuratively a gentleman's bet let's say
that sure that the US government is
working directly with Media Matters in
some way yeah yeah us us what's probably
happening is government actors and Media
Matters employees probably are in
regular communication to coordinate
their efforts and Target social media
platforms with allies who work for these
companies we know this is a fact that
the government did this now Media
Matters yet to be seen but the
government did do this with vag who had
regular meetings with them and gave them
a back door and Facebook gave the
government a back door the US government
has gone Rogue in this regard I mean we
can say they've gone Rogue in terms of
of War when was the last time the US
declared war they've gone Rogue in
basically every way you can imagine it
they don't they don't they don't take
care of the Border they violate
individual's rights by spying on them we
the I don't believe that the NSA has
stopped spying even though there's
they're supposed to have stopped
collecting metadata I don't believe they
are and the reason I don't believe they
are is because if they want they let
Google and and all the the companies
these big tech companies they let them
collect the data and then they just
subpoena it so don't their hands are
clean but if they want it you they know
that these big tech companies are going
to give it to them so they're monitoring
everything you do ring will will monitor
you with with cameras at your house
there's cameras all over every major
city the the number of individual
liberties that are specifically
protected by the Constitution is equal
to the number of individual liberties
that the federal government violates on
a regular basis but I want to throw this
in there from the post millennial Tim
cast the Benny show join Babylon B in
pledging ex adbis to fight cancel
culture we're not the only ones a large
group of people are doing this we are
putting our money where our mouth is but
let me just make sure everyone
understands when I say that timcast is
going to spend
$250,000 on X to support Elon and his
mission understand we are buying ads I'm
not just giving away free money the
other thing people should understand is
I am not saying that right now I will
write a check for $250,000
and hand it to a for ads $250,000 ad bu
unless specified it could be over a year
you know someone could be talking about
something like 10 grand or or 20 grand
per month we're so I I outlined this
specifically in my tweet saying the goal
is for in q1 of 2024 to have spent
$250,000 in ads in the first three
months and ideally 100,000 per month for
three months so that's what our Target
is that's that that's what we're talking
about doing many other people are
joining in it's not going to stem the
bleed of the massive advertisers pulling
off the platform but I must say this if
we believe that we are correct we must
support the organizations that we know
uh help us keep going you must buy
products from companies that share your
values if I'm going to buy ads in Time
Square screw that it's X from now on why
well Time Square ads were fun you know
we wanted we wanted to assert ourselves
in the mainstream space but if I
actually want conversions people who are
going to sign up for c.com and become
members X is a better place to buy ads
so I will buy from X everybody else if
you're using Twitter consider becoming a
premium user of Twitter for eight bucks
a month consider joining Benny Benny's
show at whatever membership levels he
offering is offering consider joining
The Babylon B consider joining
timcast.net
[Applause]
on Twitter but but the reality is or X
look if he uses his account to run an ad
saying X is a great platform you should
use it it's still promoting his account
yeah exactly yeah yeah like that's not
really that's what I'm saying like when
I when I run if I run a cast Brew Coffee
ad I'm not you know there there are
these leftists who are like haha these
people are rushing to give the richest
man of the world money it's like dude we
sell coffee right if if I buy an the
leftist call you the richest man in the
world no Elon oh okay they're saying
we're rushing to give the richest man in
the world money if I'm selling cash
through coffee and I spend 100 Grand in
ads and then sell 200 Grand worth of
coffee the that's how ads work yeah
that's the point anytime the leftists
start talking about like money they just
you just know they don't have any idea
what they're talking about so it doesn't
matter also who donates money to Media
Matters of like if you could donate to
any charity right now George Soros but
I'm saying individual because they say
that they get their money like there's
no way like someone's like oh I'm just
going to make my annual $20 Media
Matters I bet there is like this says
they don't disclose their donors well
yeah there's a couple people who just
philanthropy news.org says Media Matters
receives a million dollars from George
Soros
2010 so I can't imagine he
thenation do Charities not have to
disclose their donors cuz that's
Insidious it's a 501c3 yeah I don't
think you're not an individual is it a
C3 Oh I thought it was let just look C3
yes C4 no like they have to an
individual itemizing person yeah so pull
up Google search this Ian uh Media
Matters 990 990 990 those and and you
should be able to pull up easily because
they're public it's it's public record
if you want to be tax exempt then your
expenses have to be in the public record
now that doesn't mean you'll know
exactly where their money came from
it'll show you how much money they make
how much money they have it'll tell you
the salaries of their top uh staff and
employees and things like that the 990
will yep but they don't have to people
can donate I think what's happening I I
I I think it has to be public who who
donates I'm pretty sure 5 cuz uh 501 C4s
you don't have to disclose and also what
else do they do other than like I know
they do they just are
like their whole thing is just truth and
media what what do youan like like what
is their their whole thing is making up
lies in yeah but that's what what am I
say what is their stated objective as a
charity just to police truth the right
or something I do think it's funny that
like when they run an article that just
quotes me I'm like okay thank you like I
said that but I'm like do they track
like all the dishonesty on like all like
corporate media no just on the right
yeah they orig people on Twitter they
formed as a counterweight to the
conservative media Research Center and
it was like in 2004 and they were uh
known well they were known for their
criticism of uh and it's quote war on
Fox News end quote so yeah they've
always it was basically it is a the
anti- it's a propag media Research
Center and it's like if they don't have
an enemy to go after then they don't
have a reason to exist so they're like
creating
they're just they they have a the agenda
that they have is just a progressive
agenda so it's like you know if
Catholics are getting together and
they're doing Catholic things you can
narrow down like the things that they're
going to be doing because they're doing
Catholic things right like stuff that
Catholics do things that pertain to the
religion if these if you're a a
progressive Think Tank then you can kind
of narrow down where they're going to be
spending the money and who they're going
to be trying to slander and trying to uh
harm their credibility and stuff because
they're Progressive so I mean they're
going to go after obviously you know Tim
cast and they're going to go after DA
wire and they're going to go after Ben
Shiro and you know they're going to go
after Tucker Carlson but anyone that
doesn't have the narrative that comes
for the the progressive you know
narrative in in in mind they're going to
go after him yeah there must be so
little work being done at this place
like they just must be chilling all day
trying to figure out what to do I mean I
know that they're they're they just they
have people that just scour the internet
and watch like conservative shows and
then make you know posts and say look
this is why this person's bad this is
why this person you shouldn't listen to
him I mean essentially they give out
talking points yeah you know it's like
if you if you watch the content that
Media Matters puts out you as a
progressive know the people you're
supposed to hate you know why you're
supposed to hate them and you have the
surface level arguments against the
things that they're talking about
whether it be the daily stuff like we're
a topical show here they'll they would
have a topical show that would be
talking about whatever the most recent
thing that happened to that they that
they have to discredit or whether you're
talking about the more more uh Phil
philosophical stuff like okay why is it
that like you want to make sure that
trans people are represented in women's
sports or or trans women can play in
women's sports they'll have those kind
of talking points and essentially it
gives people the arguments that they can
take in into into public spaces like
Twitter or or Schoolboard meetings or
whatever and they have the AR you'll
know the argument that you're supposed
to make or that that's going to be the
most effective it's just an it's an
information distribution network is is
what it boils down to we got more big
news though from the post millennial
rumble under major DDOS attack after CEO
pledge to join Elon Musk to fight woke
sensorship this is uh man it gets
interesting every day Rumble tweeted
this out earlier today update we are
currently experiencing a major DDOS
attack our Engineers are investigating
and we will report back here with
updates a DDOS attack is a cyber crime
where the attacker floods a server with
internet traffic to prevent users from
accessing connected online services and
sites it disables the site that is
attacked uh one way to easy exp easily
explain this DDOS means distributed
denial of service so I'd like you to
imagine that there's a small door and I
have a handful of oversiz novelty germs
and when I try and shove them all
through at once they get jammed in that
door and none of them can get through
now three stes problem is a is a
Simpsons Joe yeah the three stes but
that's but that's basically what it is
right yeah they'll try to go through the
door at the same time so a DDOS hits the
server with a ton of requests the server
can't answer them all so then you're
basically stuck in this massive line
behind fake traffic so it really why and
who who would do it who has the
capability I think I saw him post that
it was coming I think they had like a
little map up and it was coming from
China
really I I think he he tweeted I could
be incorrect but I think he yeah oh here
we go looks like what is this or it's
the world doesn't like freom freedom of
expression but we will hold the line
here's a map highlighting where a good
portion of the attacks are coming from
North Korea or South Korea that looks
like North Korea I can't believe that
and those tricksters in North Korea they
don't have anything better to do take
Rumble down so these other dots also
also show China but hold on here's the
thing you can redirect your attacks to
where it's from and it China it could be
a FSE flag I'd be moreing to bet it's us
interest trying to shut down Rumble why
Rumble is joining Elon Musk Elon Musk
took away an intelligence agency asset
in manipulating public opinion because
these scumbags are evil so who has the
incentive to attack Rumble it's not
China Rumble provides free speech which
is it's it's disruptive to the Deep
state but you also State pissed you see
free Kong on Twitter so I don't think
China's any any Ally of that Network
either they don't they're not a big fan
of free speech yeah I imagine uh
Twitter's infrastructure is a lot bigger
than rumbles I could be wrong but um
Rumble too yeah yeah digital Civil War
yeah I don't know who would who would
want it to have it out for rumble
specifically Services restored earlier
today yeah it's not suris I mean imagine
people trying to go after YouTube too
which is YouTube's way too big and just
that must be just too difficult and they
no YouTube does get hit yeah they must
yeah they do it's just it's it the CEO
doesn't tweet it out when it happens no
but people do notice there there there
are often big hits to YouTube and these
things happen and also there are direct
attacks on individual youtubeers which
slow them up and cause problems for them
it's it's crazy the the level of
sophistication you can see in cyber
attacks but if if I had to make a guess
i' I'd lean towards leftist and fascist
um uh organizations on at behalf of the
US government would likely be why
rubble's being targeted but they're
losing so you add in man 2010s it's all
dominated by the Deep state by
intelligence agencies and the left and
in the beginning of the 2020s we start
to see that shift now especially with
this last year where Elon Musk man I
can't believe it's been a year right
yeah it's been a year since we all
cracked open that Louis the 13th and
cheersed when Elon Musk bought finally
remember when every the first night and
then everybody's like there's two
genders that's what everybody did
everybody goes there's two genders and
then they just waited for it boys have
girls have vaginas my God how insane is
it that before Elon Musk bought act
previously Twitter you could get banned
for saying women are not men yeah dude
it was you you go to sleep being like I
don't know if I'm going to wake up with
a Twitter account in the morning who was
it was it Megan Murphy is her name right
yeah she was on my low value mail last
week actually she got banned because she
tweeted men are not women though for
four years she was gone that's insane
yeah yeah and and and that's that's the
real reason that you know not that Media
Matters in particular is the is the
organization that has the uh you know
has the impulse that to to do this but
they're still protecting a narrative
which is the left's overarching
narrative which which obviously it's
politically correct and it aligns with
what the the federal government and
powers that be want people to think like
there is definitely a a politically
correct narrative that they're trying to
control you know the ability to discuss
this is to I I mean to call it orwellian
is almost it's almost obviously
orwellian and it almost it's using the
word so we've used the word so much in
the past two years that we've it's like
it's lost meaning but this stuff really
does matter like it's a big deal that
you can say there are only two genders
and not get punished for that like it
should never have been a thing it there
should have been massive outrage
Nationwide but because it the because of
the way that the censorship has been
instituted there was never like there
was never a time where people were like
okay we really have to you know we
really have to band together and say
something and mus kind of was the guy
that you know said this is the final
this is the last straw you can't kick
the babyon B off for making jokes you
know and thank goodness he did I mean
people do get kicked off of places for
making jokes still just not TW not X but
well you got you got I just kicked off
of well I mean I got demonetized on
YouTube like for life for a podcast clip
on my first strike ever I got uh and
then I got kicked off of Instagram in
the bud yeah this is what this is what
they're looking out for yeah big Tech
platforms know that going after Steven
Crowder is hard not only is he he
massive in terms of his audience he also
has massive resources from this which
provide him great legal defense now you
on the other hand they're probably
thinking look if this guy gets big and
gets a gets several million followers
and starts making millions of dollars
we're not going to be able to stop him
yeah stop him now before he can get big
this is what they're doing I'm going to
be Rapa they're just going to have to
put a thing on
my oh Pig dick
Instagram SL
dick great dude but but this but this is
this is the game they're playing and so
uh uh when all these leftists are like
cancel culture is not real blah blah
blah I'm like most the people who get
banned are small accounts regular
working class dude opens a Twitter
account has a couple hundred followers
tweets Maga they ban him yeah yep and
this guy has no one to tell zero
recourse yeah you like all he can tell
is his friend at work being like crazy
out here you know I keep I'm on my
eighth Twitter account or whatever and
just go yeah man the nasty thing about
censorship is when you don't know what's
happening like the Soviet Union I wonder
what it was would have been like to live
in 1954 Soviet Union like how horrifying
my parents did live in 1954 Soviet Union
it sucked were they like just not able
to talk about yeah it's like everybody's
a spy like literally the whole thing is
that everybody you know is a like my
grandmother I used to do a joke about
this my grandmother in probably right
around 1954 cuz it was right after the
war she um was living in like I think
Moscow or something in some apartment
building you know and she got a knock on
her door from her neighbor this woman
and This Woman's like hey do you have
you seen my husband like I haven't seen
my husband in a few days have you seen
him and my grandmother's like no haven't
seen him nobody hears from him for 3
years okay until a letter arrives from
the husband to the wife and what
happened is he explained he goes he was
in the lobby of the building and you
know like you live in an apartment
building you're like you know your
neighbors you're making small talk and
he goes to one of his neighbors he goes
hey you want to like hear a joke and
the's like oh okay whatever and he tells
him a joke and it was an anti-government
joke and then the neighbor ratted him
out and he got 10 years in Siberia for
literally just telling like you know
just in passing Small Talk want to hear
a joke it's like Soviet gray Russia like
let's lighten things up it's like the
stories I've heard are worse than that
but I'm saying that's 10 years of break
you know breaking Stones stories uh the
story that I mentioned that I've told
before is a friend of mine from Ukraine
said in this apart there's two
apartments they're next to each other
it's like an old communist style Soviet
block and there were there were two
families that lived there and they did
not like each other so one day one
family said I got an idea called the
police and said oh they're making
anti-government statements the next day
the whole apartment was empty man and it
makes me think that guy in the lobby
when you're that that guy went and told
the joke to the guy the guy who's
hearing the joke is could could be
thinking like this could be a government
agent testing me to see if I'm going
everybody spies right so you're like
it's it's real like Game Theory where
that guy's like well if I don't report
him like I might be tested right now so
if I don't do it then like you want to
be the first person to act almost right
and I I guarantee that there are tons of
people in corporate America that lived
like that all the time in fear of using
the wrong pronoun or saying the wrong
you know saying the wrong thing or
whatever and it's not as dramatic as
people go to the goog but they just lose
their job because they get they go to HR
and HR fires them you know because they
said something insensitive and so you're
you're you're constantly afraid I can't
make this comment I can't say this and
if I don't call someone out if I do hear
something it could someone could see or
overhear us and then I get implicated
too so it's that fear that keeps
everybody in line that's why it's so
important for people just stand up and
say F you I'm not doing it I'm not doing
that at all we pretty much have kicked
the bucket over but I I could see like a
a totalitarian social media system where
if you're watching video you're online
browsing and you see something that
should be reported and you don't report
it they're going to be like they flag
your account that's not going to happen
in the United States because we got AE
of the ball but I could see that in
like front facing camera turns on and
you just get why did you not record I'm
not so confident that it's that it's
that it's that it wouldn't happen here
like it's not over here this fight is
not over we live in kind of a bubble so
we see the people that are fighting back
but I I'm not so confident that that's
something that's hit the broader country
yet and understand this
Danny they're already turning your front
facing camera on to take pictures oh for
sure so uh a couple years ago I had I
there's a there's a phone I forgot what
it's called the McLaren phone or
whatever and the front- facing camera is
mechanical it when you turn it on to
take a picture it slide it goes and
slides out so my girlfriend I I'm like
hey I'm going to get a Galaxy you can
use my phone instead and then she's
browsing a website when all a sudden the
camera comes up and then goes right down
what that means is on a regular
day-to-day basis your front-facing
camera is probably taking pictures of
you so everybody out there I know what
you're doing on those websites they're
probably taking pictures of you no joke
oh those are not flattering photos
facial expression not not flattering
photos
[Laughter]
I mean and who knows that picture but
with the cancel culture like I mean like
this is you know more my industry but
like there's no comedy shows or movies
anymore you know like when was the last
like can you name a comedy TV show right
now New York City right now has the
biggest promotion every bus and every
taxi cab right now for Big Bang Theory a
TV show that's not even on anymore and
was never funny to begin with even
regardless of what you even think about
that it's not on right now why are they
promoting it like it's like the new hit
show of like I guess maybe the strike or
what but like it's huge promotion but
like there's no comedy shows anymore is
it because people aren't taking risks
yes because like you can't take like
nobody wants to take risks because of
like basically the the essentially like
climate and then you know like you who
wants to be caught at work laughing at a
joke that is like going to get you fired
at work you know like you can't talk
like there's so New York's already
commie dude you're not going you're not
going to go back go to work and talk
around the
the last big dude was 2014 that's why
I'm not there yeah like the last like
huge hit comedy movie was 10 years ago
what was it I think it was Ted 2 oh my
gosh and that like where it made like
really like in the like in the top like
I think it's in the top 50 or something
something like that like there has not
been a blockbuster com in full of jokes
that put you in jail now I'd say TV show
wise Rick and Morty would uh not get
super offensive but they got rid of
Justin royland yeah well exactly I I
mean I'll say uh it's always s in
Philadelphia South Park say new ones new
ones like any sort of like the only
things are still exist are these
holdovers from literally like why don't
why don't we make a show years ago like
a modern version of Seinfeld called
polish Chuck mhm sure I don't know if
that's the best title but
um but it might actually be I don't know
yeah maybe maybe maybe it's so bad that
it's good but but sure it's just the
problem is is like in terms of
distribution you know you can get on
YouTube but then they go hey we we just
gave you a strike yeah on Rumble and
then you know we're not far away from
from being able to do that for sure are
are your comedy shows like um somber do
people get lit up and laugh standup is
standup is untouched like standup is
obviously like if you go watch standup
on like Comedy Central or something
you'll you like if you go look at like
uh like I do live streams on YouTube for
my shows and sometimes when I'm doing a
live stream like Comedy Central their
YouTube page like this is how bad it's G
for them and how badly they destroyed
their brand where they have
11.6 million subscribers on YouTube and
they'll do these standup live streams
and there'll be 300 people
watching because there're just like
nobody like the YouTube algorithm
stopped showing their thing to anybody
that subscribed to them because people
rejected it for so long that they're
just like all because they're doing woke
stuff they just at some point everybody
signed up for Comedy Central because
they like Bill bur and Dave Chappelle
and all Kevin Hart all that stuff and
then basically right around Trump which
is like a lot of stuff they were you
know all the diversity stuff and they go
hey we need to have this needs to be
more representative and you go you can't
just just cuz someone is a certain
category like doesn't make them good at
comedy that's true for literally
everything yes exactly but comedy is
really true and so and it's like you
know it's very evident like at least
there's some stuff that's like you know
whatever art fear not good sir fear not
fear not fil Fe we are winning Phil
knows the story I'm pulling up I do
Argentina elect anarco capitalist Javier
mle president today Begins the end of
Argentina's decline said The Economist
during his victory speech and I think I
have a a video for you that we're going
to play so you can understand who this
guy is I hope you speak Spanish because
here we go
Min okay he said Ministry of culture
out treasury
out
gender and diversity
[Laughter]
out I mean mayor Adams is about to do
this in New York City but just not not
on not cuz he wants to they just have
crazy budget they're closed libraries on
weekends now was complaining about it
that's now hold on hear me out this
could be like a Libertarian Paradise
okay in Argentina no in New York City
New York City the cops are destroyed you
can't do anything about it all right and
if you here's what happens first it's uh
uh it's it's a stable liberal neoliberal
state so there's a bunch of laws then
things start breaking down and you get
anarco tyranny but after tyranny you get
the collapse of government institutions
you get Anarchy yeah the problem is you
can't have guns no no no no no that's
anarco tyranny like the cops will be
like well this law biding citizen is
going to prison but once the Anarchy
phase happens and there's no cops
anymore been abolished now you can do
whatever you want I do not want to live
in New York City when you can do
whatever you want so so here you are now
Argentina elects Javier mle this is a
guy who's roasted the left he's called A
M over and over again just like
you swear in different language because
most people don't know what you're
saying but uh some people are saying as
brexit s uh signaled the victory of
Donald Trump in the next election United
States this right here this is a
landslide victory for an anti-woke
anarcho capitalist yeah a lot of people
are like it Trump's going to win there's
there's something that people need to
recall or think about when it comes to
this guy like Argentina has like
150% inflation or something like that so
the prices have tripled since 2020 yeah
comparing Argentina I think that's what
I saw is there no but I mean like yeah
what do you think's going out with the
average average person it's not it's not
150% we're talking about like the York
City it was dollar sliced pizza now it's
$150 Pizza there's no dollar sliced
pizza in New York City and also this has
been this has been going on in Argentina
for multiple years too like and it was
going on long before like our our
inflation kicked in in the past you know
two years it's been going on in and and
the only reason I'm saying this is
because libertarian ideas as much as I
like them the average person is not at
the point where they're like screw the
whole government yet so the the American
the American population look though and
I and again you're talking to a guy that
loves the idea of cutting the government
as much as possible I'm just trying top
is winning among 18 to 34 year olds I
mean he's not badly losing in New York
right now which is crazy cuz he should
be smoke New York is D plus 27 and
Biden's winning by 10 yeah that's insane
insan insane and the poll oversampled
two to one Democrats it should be way
higher higher I 100% like everything
you're saying I just want I want people
that in America to to remember to to at
least remember that Argentina's
conditions and the United States
conditions are significantly different
you know what this kind of reminds me of
sorry is uh you know how when when Elon
bought Twitter and then he fired 2/3 of
everyone who there and everyone goes I
wonder how this is going to work out
because if he can fire 2/3 of everybody
why can't Facebook go fire and YouTube
and all the stuff so like I wonder if
this is going to kind of be like a bit
of a test run where he goes you know
what we don't need a cultural diversity
committee we definitely whatever and he
was going to scrap it and he'll probably
be like look it's fine I I'm I went to
the grocery store the other night and uh
we like to buy these these little
salamis I don't know if you guys have
seen we in the basement where it's like
three different kinds and there's maybe
like 20 slices of each it was $112 for a
pack yeah dude a year and a a year or so
ago it was like $750 oh yeah and so when
we were ringing them up my girlfriend's
like this is $12 and I'm like whoa oh
yeah that's crazy dude I mean yeah I go
out for to eat in New York and a lot of
times you know like you'll go on uh
Google Maps or whatever and then they'll
have the menu on there and a lot of
times the menu that they'll have on in
Google Maps will be like 2 years old old
and then you go in there and you see the
difference from 2 years ago and you go
wow like literally and it's never going
back dude like like a Taco Taco Bells
like what what is it like three bucks an
hour or something yeah no no no like a
gordita crunch or whatever is like 350
yeah what was it a MCD double is
$3 be a dollar in a couple years you'll
have the $5 menu for the stuff that used
to be the dollar menu but the key thing
is it's like certain like for
Commodities Commodities are competitive
and they will probably but like for
prices at a restaurant and stuff like
they're not it's the grocery it's not
going back like eggs can maybe come down
or whatever but like restaurants they
don't lower prices I'll tell you this I
went to the grocery store and uh I like
me some heavy whipping cream in my
coffee yeah they didn't have it and
consistently now over the past year the
grocery store has not been carrying
heavy cream and when they do we grab
some and then it's gone for a few months
so we have to go to other places we have
to go to local farms or one of the
specialty organic shops to get like the
organic farm cream but a couple of our
local grocery stores typically don't
carry it all that often now I'll tell
you my I'll tell you my theory yeah I'm
wondering if the margin profit margin
for derivative products is higher than
for the the pure product meaning if if
the if the company says we can sell a
pint uh uh or you know whatever little
little carton a pint of heavy cream and
we'll make $1 per per carton or whatever
if we take that same amount of cream and
sell it to people who are going to make
whipped cream or butter we might make $2
per pint because of the derivatives I'm
wondering if that's why the production
has gone down and the stores aren't
caring it as much very possibly I mean
shrink flation is also crazy right now
truth social filed a defamation lawsuit
against 20 media companies this is
breaking in the past 10 minutes 10
minutes ago 10 minutes ago disclosed
pleas don't be Tim cast please don't be
Tim cast
please well we'll pull that up in the
next one we'll wrap this one up and
we'll pull that one up in a second so
yeah Javier is uh I mean it's in my
opinion it's great I love the idea of of
giving uh anarco capitalist or live
there let's just let it ride man I mean
the thing is I think that they're going
to they're going to work you know at
least in the short term because the
conditions that they've set up in the
past in Argentina everyone is everything
is is so all the money that they they
have is going straight to government and
government industry or debt servicing is
cost are like I'm sure they're going to
have to they're going they've gone like
I think they've they've they've had like
three times they've had to restructure
their debt so they'll have to do it
again because they have to get dollars
to Peg their by the way the fact that
the United States did not re like re
service their dead like two years ago or
whatever a low insane I don't I don't
even I don't even want to talk about it
because there's nothing that can be done
and when when interest rates were zero
and they're like people were like why
don't you ref and that was also when
Trump was like hey we should refill the
Strategic petroleum thing when gas was
like or yeah everybody was like well the
fact that you're suggesting it means we
shouldn't so yeah so yeah I mean that is
a frustrating turn of events that when
things were cheap and and and good we
and it seemed like obviously in
hindsight it seems so obvious you go
interest rates couldn't be lower
possibly I guess I guess the problem was
Trump at one moment tried to be like
maybe we should take these bad boys
negative I don't know I I can't I can't
speak to that I don't know at all so
this Malay guy I thought at first he may
nervous cuz he was screaming about and
he was angry and screaming I'm like H
that sounds like Hitler but then I gave
him a chance I was like let's hear this
you know where Hitler lives right now uh
is he in Belgium he AR in Argentina he
was
bar um but then I started watching him
and I I really really liked his
personality M's personality and also I
didn't know but he wants to take
Argentina off the peso and put him on
the US dollar well they're going to Peg
the peso to the dollar I imagine the CIA
is behind this guy now and that's
probably why he won I don't know man CIA
was was likely behind uh Lula in Brazil
and that didn't work out great I don't
think the CIA would be behind a guy like
this I think the CIA would be opposed to
a guy like this because nowadays the the
the the federal government and the P
like the you know the narrative that is
pushed is not a right-wing small
government narrative it's definitely a
big government I thought the powers that
be the authoritarian powers of be would
not want him in power because he's a
populist libertarian but then the people
are like well but the liberal econ order
needs all the help it can get so if
Argentina wants to join as a as a
partner by taking the US Dollar on then
maybe it's worth it because this whole
crypto like economy thing is is very Pro
it's it's promising it's better than
just sucking it in and being like well
in 10 years my car is going to cost
$350,000 oh well that's not sustainable
so like and it just can't get much much
worse for them like they're just
obviously at a point where enough people
are like you know what it just this guy
cannot screw it up worse than it already
has been screwed up all right I I I know
ladies and gentl we got so much news
here we got breaking news um we've got a
truth social filing defamation case it's
massive it's breaking we're going to get
to that in a second because we have more
breaking news right now this is tweeted
from Elon Musk he says fraud has both
civil and criminal penalties Ken Paxton
attorney general has in uh of the great
state of Texas has announced an
investigation into Media Matters for
potential fraud saying the Office of the
Attorney General is opening an investig
ation into Media Matters for potential
fraudulent activity under the Texas
Bureau organizations's code and
deceptive Trade Practices Act the oag
will vigorously enforce against
nonprofits who commit fraudulent acts in
or affecting the state of Texas Attorney
General Paxton was extremely troubled by
the allegations that Media Matters a
radical anti-free speech organization
fraudulently manipulated data on X
formerly known as Twitter quote we are
examining the issue closely to ensure
the public has not been deceived by the
schemes of radical leftwing
organizations who would like nothing
more than to limit free speech by
reducing participation in the Public
Square said attorney general Paxton
ladies and gentlemen come on there we go
tell me you are red you you are
blackpilled okay we are looking at a
major turn Ken Paxton of course I'm not
surprised to see him doing this this
dude means
business if Missouri follows suit
because they announced first they were
looking into it Paxton probably saw that
was like hey man we're on board
announces this potential criminal invest
are literal criminal investigation poal
criminal charges of the people at Media
Matters I got to say this Elon Musk IP
ban all Media Matters employees no
question if you want to argue Free
Speech I'll argue Free Speech if you
want to argue they disliked things that
were said argue things they they they
disliked things but if you are saying
you have proof they manipulated the
platform for fraudulent activities you
are the judge and the jury here so I
think it's fair to say if you you are
using a platform to engage in fraud
criminal and civil tort violations then
you should be banned Martin scy replied
to that tweet by Elon Musk and he just
goes can
confirm I'm friends with him he's man
God has consequences he seems
great is the man oh he's so funny on at
least on X I know a lot of people hate
him I think he's hilarious I think he's
great what's uh if this Media Matters
gets found guilty liable for fraud and
everything then what would they have to
pay out criminal is like that's criminal
I it's going to be the people so what's
going to happen is with a a a fraud
investigation for a charity they're not
going to go Media Matters committed
fraud they're going to say John Smith
whoever the fake name you know John Doe
or Jane Doe said these things
fraudulently in an effort to engage in
these behaviors so they'll take out the
employees that committed fraud will get
their their criminal filings and then
the company itself is it going to take a
civil hit cuz it's got got 11 million in
Assets in
21 I think this might be the end yeah
but like what stops just some new
operation from just kind of all they do
is just like follow 30 Twitter accounts
and and here's the issue with going up
against government Texas has effectively
unlimited funds yeah you're you're 11
million assets bro that that's that's
not enough to maintain a couple car
dealerships in 2021 was there their what
they had on hand was 11 million and so
what I imagine happening now is facing a
massive lawsuit from Elon Musk an
investigation from Ken Paxton they're
going to get buried in legal paperwork
they're not going to be able to aford
afford the lawyers they deserve it they
they've really really screwed the pooch
on this they went too far if they
actually doctored up images to get EX um
well they just miss advertisers to leave
the company that is the issue is they
they didn't have to do it before but
they're desperate what what is happening
now with the narrative machine the the
neoliberal neoconservative unip party is
they are so desperate because they're
losing every day they have to engage in
more more and more extreme activities it
used to be that they could make a phone
call to one of their cult members at
Twitter and they'd say okay we
understand we'll do as we're told the
FBI right the FBI calls up and says you
know we just think this shouldn't be
there if you get our drift like you got
it boss now they're calling Elon and
he's like well actually I'm the richest
man in the world so I got more you
money than you can imagine have a nice
day and now they're like what do we do
there's nothing we have elon's done
nothing wrong so they must now fabricate
it and that's risky and it's a losing
strategy and they're going to lose
because of it and the funny thing is
they've been doing this stuff for so
long that probably never crossed
anybody's mind that this was a bad idea
they've been just getting away with this
forever and they nobody probably said
hey this isn't maybe the best idea to do
this yeah it was like it was
incrementally getting worse well they
just have like probably have never had
any they've probably done this to tons
of companies right and just kept getting
they go yeah look how many companies we
shut down like it's works well a lot of
companies probably just say we'll we'll
do what you tell us yeah media matter
says hey you said a naughty word and
they go okay fine we'll take it down
because it's easier than dealing with a
lawsuit yeah now they tried they they
just ripped away probably you know like
half a billion in ad Revenue potentially
and Twitter can prove it the funny thing
is these these companies don't get it
they're going to be on the hook for 500
million plus oh they'll just yeah
they'll go bankrupt they'll cease to
exist overnight Now Fair Point they will
start another one and try and reopen
another one but precedent is being set
if Republican AGS are now willing to go
after for criminal charges they will not
be able to spit up another company the
the basic strategy of hey elon's racist
didn't work yeah it didn't work anymore
it used to work it used to be hey elon's
racist and then the CEO be like no no no
no no no I'm not no I'm not Advertiser
threaten a boycott they'd say oh Mia
copi so sorry and then everyone would
say okay now that you've pledged to the
cult you're free to go but that's not
working anymore Elon buys Twitter and
laughs in their faces so what do they do
now they have to take it to an extreme
doctoring a circumstance in order to try
and get advertisers to pull out out and
now it's easily provable yo Discovery is
going to be a yeah yeah this is
this will be interesting to see if
there's actual criminal charges that
it's be beyond that Discovery may lead
to Expo government exposure yeah yeah I
I'm willing to bet you will find
Communications between Media Matters and
people in government no
question well I'd love to see who funds
them I'm just they're paying out 6
million in wages in 2021 and I bet it's
like one guy getting a million bucks 1.6
million to the executives and then
another 6 million to other salaries you
can actually you can look up you can
look up the salaries explicitly like you
can look up their the Nam and how much
money they I'm more interested in what
kind of like what do they produce you
know like what like if you even ask them
like what have you done it's the we call
out rightwing
information they have a uh uh a a
mission statement on the uh so they're
Community notes basically they've been
just replaced by Community notes
essentially like that's what you do is
you just start Community notes yeah but
but look Community notes is is real
though it can be manipulated Media
Matters just makes things up yeah no
it's it's it's a 501c3 Progressive
research and information center
dedicated to comprehensively monitoring
analyzing and corrective conservative
correcting conservative misinformation
in the US media so it's literally a
propaganda outfit looking to do what it
can to harm people that have different
opinions digital snitching yeah I mean
it's beyond that now because they went
out of their way to fake evidence it's I
mean call that fabrication of evidence
fraud it's it's it's man torous
interference is crazy enough right like
if Phil and Danny had a contract and
then I went to Phil and said cancel that
contract with a Danny or else that's
torous interference yeah they're doing
that but they're also fabricating
evidence in order to get away with it
that's crazy with one of the most
high-profile to thew put some people on
blast that work for the company this is
in 2021 Angela kuson is that how you
pronounce your president CE that guy
like an anti half a million dollars that
year I don't know but he posted he he
has like a history of posting a bunch of
racist stuff doesn't he uh I mean if you
go back far enough in most people's
Twitter and stuff you get some some
interesting stuff yeah you don't want to
see the conversations I had at Taco Bell
when I was
14 I don't know any of these people
David Brock is that the guy that founded
Media Matters in 2004 he's still the
chairman of the company made 300 Grand
200 for what yeah exactly he you guys
find any misinformation today no I'll be
around twice a year for a one hour call
keep looking guys there's lots of
misinformation out there you got got to
go watch all the uh the right-wing media
and then like some job for someone who
just literally just watches Ben of here
all day that Mis information that's
that's what they do literally yes
literally and then they get on the
internet and they're like a
about it yeah what's your job really
formal reports stuff like what's your
job I watch Ben Shapiro and I'm an
about it
what more can you expect yeah well I
don't know how you guys could be
blackpilled I mean we're I I think we're
winning I and I I think the important
things to understand is this on the
battlefield when when you see the enemy
break ranks you don't say okay we're
done you say charge yeah now more than
ever and you know what I want to say it
was a few weeks ago I said this and now
I what I think we're actually seeing is
the the the storming of the battlefield
all of these lawsuits these people
pushing back the pledges to sponsor uh
to buy on X this is everyone basically
saying we
winning Full Speed Ahead and you know
what feels like the Cavalry going in to
finish the route is the government
picking up the lawsuit the Texas state
government and who was it Missouri state
government is that who said Missouri AG
said he was looking into it and a is and
AG of Texas announced an investigation
that's that's the Cavalry coming in oh
that's the riters of Rohan dude L
looking up the hill and that light
shining down I'm not sure how Battle of
Helms Deep will be won I'm not sure how
accurate this is but someone is tweeting
that the judge that will be hearing the
Elon mus bomb shell lawsuit against
Media Matters was appointed by Donald
Trump judge Mark T Pittman is the same
judge that ordered the FDA to release
the fiser files oo oh going to get fun
my are there any nonpartisan like
misinformation Charities like are they
all just partisan they're all partisan
all partisan because misinformation was
the term misinformation in modern
Parliament has been created to say stuff
that doesn't line up with the official
narrative if it's misinformation it just
means things the government doesn't want
you to think ladies and gentlemen we are
not done we have more breaking news a
tweet from Chris pavlovski the CEO
Rumble says truth social just filed an
unprecedented defamation lawsuit
incorporating 20 media companies The
Tide is finally turning corporate media
and activists are going to feel the heat
I want you this Thursday when you're
sitting down with your family to say I'm
thankful for the lawsuits that are being
filed against these evil neocon
neoliberal organizations truth social
posts on Truth they truthed today truth
social filed the defamation lawsuit that
is likely unprecedented in history
incorporating 20 Publications and even
uh and and even more may be added all of
them published the same false
information about truth social and
refused to fully retract their stories
to the fake news adlets that think
themselves above accountability we'll
see you in court we get it right here
filed 11223 this is a crazy week man in
the Circuit Court of the 12th Judicial
Court in for Sarasota County Florida
Civil Division Trump media and
technology versus here we go Guardian
news and media LLC Hollywood Reporter
the mcache company we have the M Miami
heral Alex Mena Reuters News Rolling
Stone nextstar media the hill deadline
Hollywood aive Capital LLC B Ben
benzinga marketwatch.com Forbes media
axios The Daily Beast company go media
doing business as Gizmodo salon.com New
York Daily News Newsweek MSN NBC cable
LLC oh I'm sorry MSNBC cable LLC
mediaite DMG media Daily Mail and
CNBC wow wow so uh they say this number
wow this is crazy I heard this news this
case is about an unprecedented and
seemingly coordinated media campaign by
no less than 20 major Outlets to attack
Trump media they say uh by falsely
reporting that tmtg had lost $73 million
remember we heard this a few days ago oh
no not look I got to tell you there's a
lot of people who will be like oh why is
you know oh oh Tim C is talking about
the story but that story came out
earlier in the day or came out yesterday
the reason is we fact check and verify
things this story came out I read it and
said I'm not going anywhere near this
story yeah and turns out once again it
was fake news this they say this number
was an utter fabrication each defendant
in apparent coordination reported the
exact same false number within
approximately 24 hours of one another
each citing to a public Securities and
Exchange Commission filing in which the
mystery $73 million loss appears
nowhere okay who start I want do you
know who originated this I I I the the
fake news no who origin because seems
like it's one of those things because
there's no real like journalism a lot of
these um like sites or whatever is
probably just one person started it and
Rolling Stones like okay but they're
saying they all cited an SEC filing oh
so this is so but no no no but you're
right someone checked on that so here's
here's the big deal times V Sullivan the
actual malice standard would require for
this lawsuit to proceed the news
organizations had to know what they were
printing was false that's the actual
Mala standard now these companies are in
a serious steeming pile of donkeyish if
you know what I mean they are going to
have to argue when they cited the SEC
document they were unaware the number
did not appear in it yeah at admitting
in court we did not actually read
anything we wrote they're going to have
to admit what everybody already knows
which is that they're not really
journalists they're just are content
creators essentially that they don't
facture yeah they're just like yeah we
don't that's hilarious I mean I just saw
and I rewrote it I don't know I assumed
it was true I don't know yeah look man I
mean that's crazy let me let me give you
an example I hope I hope they lose
there's this story um about this kid in
I think it was Vegas who got stopped to
death by a bunch of kids yeah and so one
guy tweets 15 black kids Beat to Death
beat a white kid to death and it's not
being covered because of race blah blah
blah and everyone picks it up and so I
watch the video and sure enough there's
six kids not 15 two of them are not
black uh four maybe or maybe three we're
not sure and there's a lot more to the
story than just this people don't care
about what the they just keep retweeting
the same thing over and over again I
stopped and I said I'm not I'm not going
to I'm not going to go anywhere near
this I this this is clearly not true and
I got to the point where so many people
had published the fake news I made a
segment where I was just like dude this
is fake news yeah so yeah he should not
have been beaten to death but this is
the problem with the corporate press
they see a story and they say roll with
it here's the link not a single person
read the SEC filing I I I actually think
there's a strong possibility they knew
it was a false number and reported
anyway yeah because it helps them in
some way they're probably all like you
know what we can't have Donald Trump
getting elected I'm sure all 20 of these
organizations feel that way where if
they can get any sort of piece of
information that'll come out that'll
hurt him in any way they're like let's
get it out and they just that's the
objective is this is big though too
because uh truth social is under I
believe dwac yeah which is a publicly
traded company yeah so this negative
press means people probably started
selling off stock like crazy for sure
and now there's massive damages yeah
this going to be huge come on so are you
blackpilled still I mean this is this is
tremendous people are fighting back in
huge numbers it's crazy that these
businesses don't have like a fiduciary
obligation to like they like the actual
just just keeping their own businesses
Al alive you know to just be smarter
than that but I don't I guess I don't
know who's running these things because
well I mean if their goal if Ian like
market watch and CNBC didn't check on
that like I understand Rolling Stone
they don't know what their head from
their ass but like CNBC didn't check NBC
News may as well be Media Matters yeah
NBC News has a political team that is
known no question and not is
non-controversial for making things up
in one instance they even ran a picture
of me on the Today's Show over a fake
story it's been a long time but the
writer included a false statement and
then a bunch of other outlets like
variety and I think deadline picked the
story up cited the false News NBC within
minutes removed the false citation so it
was out of their story creating a
circular Loop of fake news with no
Source it's it's masterful what they do
and how they create fake and they
probably got away with it for so long
like they were probably doing this for
decades there must have been some sort
of buffer period where like journalism
there was like legitimate like you know
journalism like the Watergate all that
stuff and then it switched over to this
slowly and nobody called them on it
forever this kind of stuff didn't is a
is a phenomenon that has arisen with the
internet with the internet like the the
as long as there was like cable news you
had your general well well the thing is
I I think about that sometimes though
because if they wanted to spread some
fake story before the internet it would
have been even harder to refute because
if that one person can't get sort of
like you know TV show to cover them but
it wasn't as polarized and like people
weren't attacking other Americans like
that had different opinions if you think
about it like when I started like
watching news a lot was right after 9/11
right so that 911 happened and it's like
okay that's what I'm paying attention to
news and I used to watch MSNBC all the
time and from like 2001 until
2010 2009 something like that MSNBC was
perfectly it seemed perfectly normal
normal right like Joe Scarboro had a
nighttime show and he was a you know he
was a republican that acted like a
Republican and sounded like you know
your standard Republicans and stuff and
it was in like 2010 2011 when you
started when I stopped watching MSNBC
because I just felt like it didn't have
anything other than the progressive
perspective so I think that that once
the internet and social once social
media became so popular and you had your
big tech company starting to realize and
and make moves with the
powerful you know products that they
created um I think that's when it really
started so I think I think this all ties
in with the whole social media and your
cell phone yeah probably all the whole
like click getting I want to I want to
give people an example to understand why
you never talk to the Press you may have
heard uh about that famous Supreme Court
Justice who said don't talk to Cops well
don't talk to journalists either for any
reason now you can talk to a jour Jal
said they come from a publication that
you know as honor and integrity and and
you're a fan of that's totally fine but
any corporate mainstream press avoid a
guy named Andrew morance he is a scumbag
he is an evil lying prick who writes
fake stories for a living interviewed me
uh several years ago he took my quotes
and manipulated them to change what I
said but his argument basically is you
literally said these words didn't you I
can place them in any order I want so he
took two different quotes from like 30
minutes apart put them next to each
other to create a fake story when Vice
news took issue with the lie that he
published this is what he writes an
earlier version of this article included
a quotation from Tim pool concerning
Vice news's coverage in Ferguson the
quotation has been removed because it
contains several errors yeah it's
deceptive editing the errors were his
yeah but he made it seem like the errors
were mine so even though he lied in his
story when he got caught even when
they're forced to correct under threat
of lawsuit they still blamed me for the
fake story they wrote yeah and they
probably the language was vague enough
where they go you know maybe someone
will interpret it that we but they were
kind of making it out there so when I
when I called and had my lawyer talk to
them and threatened they said what do
you mean there were quotes from Tim pool
we did remove them and they did contain
errors and we said yes the errors were
yours and they said everything we said
was factual yeah and even if they do
even if you finally get a retraction
from them at that point it's like this
is the New York the quotes didn't have
errors in them the positioning of the
quotes created an error it's deceptive
editing you like a good Simpsons
reference it's the gummy Venus demo ex
absolutely you know it's just like yes
that's that happened and so I told him I
know you recorded the conversation
release the audio tapes he's like no and
the audio tapes prove that he F he
created and there's I mean there's been
no shortage of people like Dave porno
all the time where people want to
interview him he goes okay fine happy to
interview just let me record it and they
go no right he go what do you mean like
I'll just I just want to hit record on
my phone and because never talk to never
talk to these people on the phone
they'll call you up and they'll say hey
how's it going you'll say pretty good
they'll like what' you have for dinner
you like uh Pizza I'm like thanks bye
click then they'll write he called me on
the phone and made an and engag in an
anti-semitic screed and you like no I
didn't but he did here's the phone
record that proves it yeah exactly they
just lie they will lie and then what are
you supposed to do when you sue they'll
be like you're honor we had the
conversation he called me what do you
want me to say and they'll be like okay
there you go and you know for you it's
just like the hassle of suing unless you
have a ton of time and money on your
hands just for most people it's not even
worth doing or it's just
and they probably got away with it for
so long that they're just like yeah this
is what we do this is how we operate
let's talk about uh we got we're GNA
we're going to get spicy with it ladies
and gentlemen well we got a lot of crazy
news going on these days and it seems
like there's a lot of good news with
these lawsuit and stuff here's a story
from Tim cast.com Democrat Congressman
says Trump quote has to be eliminated
he's not only unfit he is destructive to
our democracy it's not a joke it is a
literal quote uh let me play the clip
for you and uh we'll get it going Trump
of course now and his recent true social
post uh is incredibly incredibly scary
for anyone uh that might be trying to
work in government and um it is just uh
unquestionable at this point that that
man cannot see public office again he is
not only unfit he is destructive to our
democracy uh and he has to be uh he has
to be eliminated our democracy means not
yours he has to be eliminated now now
hold on this story is from uh today
published by Adrian Norman at
timcast.net
saying he is in excellent health of
course the implication is Trump is for
one trying to earn votes by saying I'm
healthy but also there is a serious
concern that something may happen to him
yeah today well today's also Joe Biden's
81st birth birthday happy birthday Jo he
blew it in the uh in the in the what was
it the partying of the turkey today or
something like that what did he kill him
no he just he was so like out of it he
just snapped the turkey neck got
confused I was supposed to do that man
he was he was confused between uh Taylor
Swift Britney Spears and Rihanna I think
oh okay yeah yeah I think yeah yeah yeah
what were they thinking putting a guy
with who's suffering Dementia in front
of a prompt well they're not admitting
it though they're like what are you
supposed to do but I'm saying like you
give a tell a prompt teleprompter with
words he doesn't recognize and names he
doesn't know and he's like Taylor Spears
Brit brittana I don't know what I'm
talking about here I mean yeah it's
honestly like kind of sad at this point
cuz we would never treat any 81-year-old
this way if they weren't the president
look look you ever see that viral video
of the girl on Tik Tok wearing the
Nirvana shirt and she's like I don't
know what this is yeah it just everyone
wears this shirt and it's like it's not
just that he's old it's just that it's
out of his generation and they're trying
to make like they're trying to attract
young voters by having him say this yeah
Taylor Swift yeah sorry dude not going
to work I will say with this this like
bad for democracy thing that they
they're saying about you know destroying
democracy they've been saying this now
for eight years yeah like I was promised
that he would destroy democracy I was
like I was living in Canada in a
different country and they promised me I
I put money on it and I I'm still
waiting to get they literally promised
me they go that the destruction of
democracy is imminent if he's elected
then he was elected then we went through
a full term a pandemic a like you know
all all this in like all this stuff and
we're still it seems like bid was
elected that it would save democracy
that's what I'm saying they always like
you can't say twice that he's going to
destroy democracy you had your chance to
say that he was going to destroy it it's
not destroyed move on to something else
about him he's got to
destroy whatever the
Hitler and and the you know he's worse
than Hitler and blah blah blah they
they've literally run out of but you
can't say the same adjectives obviously
you can because they have been I know
they can be but you're like if if this
premise was but hear me out Michael
Rapaport says Pig dick Donald Trump yeah
that's a new one yeah okay but he says
he's also going to vote for him but I
don't I don't know really new one I I
don't know if someone with a pig dick
would be a dictator or what that has to
do with whether a good or bad leader
that's a good point but it is an
adjective yeah you know but it's an ad
it's a different one yeah it's a
different one it's a different adjective
there you go some Trump did some stuff
that was like what you would call the
bad gu stuff like he in my opinion he
made his family in positions of power
which I was like I don't like when
politicians do that when they're not
qualified yeah um you know he gave
fouchy the reins of control with the the
medical
techn had R of control Trump should have
put aop to yeah Trump stood behind him
on stage and like gave him all this
yeah yeah I'm just saying the whole
destroying democracy Come Close more
like status quo with a little with a
little goodness sprinkled on he gave his
generals control the the drones the
Drone Warfare he gave that to his
generals his clandestine drone Warfare
which is like well that's supposed to be
the president's job to decide who gets
droned not the generals uh other than
that neily not necessarily those doesn't
need to doesn't need to be in fact if
you look at like the way that Vietnam
went down when when Nixon was was
getting I think it was Nixon or no LBJ
was getting involved in like which
targets were going to be bombed that was
really problematic for the for the war
itself so not trying to stomp on you so
go ahead well I don't know if that he
did it in order to make them clandestine
or if they were already clandestine but
he made secret droning bomb campaigns
basically um but other than those three
things putting family in power giving
the country over to fouchy and the the
secret drone bombs he didn't do anything
like super bad what's that saying of uh
don't let the uh perfect be the enemy of
the good be the enemy of yeah so like
that's the that's the thing about like
criticizing Trump over like oh his
family was in government okay yeah and
Joe Biden was giving his brother and his
son money the counter is Biden his
family power
too Hing your kid is one thing running
secret back room deals with with
adversarial Nations to benefit your
family Trump wasn't doing that as far as
I can tell he wasn't sending off Don Jr
to go be on the board of some North
Korean Energy company and I've listened
to Jared kusher on a few podcasts he's
pretty sharp guy I don't know I can't
speak to Milan or no ianka yeah yeah but
jar kushan is pretty smart guy I think
they're all fairly smart people yeah I
mean but anyways if he did destroy
democracy he would still be president
and there would not be an election next
year like that would be in my mind what
the destruction of democracy would be is
that we would just be a dictator for
life kind of thing we have the whole
Spectrum okay Roseanne and a retired
Colonel McGregor both think there won't
be an election next year really what
does Rosanne think Rosanne thinks there
won't be an election like and then what
it's going to be Biden oh I don't know
but she said there won't be an election
and Michael mes has $1,000 bet with her
so if she's wrong she's got to pay
Michael $1,000 she'll be but what
happens if there's the VIS of an
election where everyone puts in their
votes and then nothing happens that's
clarified I asked her I said do you mean
like nobody votes and everyone's like oh
no no election or it's like Trump's
removed so it's not a legitimate
election and she said I think that one I
think that's what she basically said
like it's going to be a weird thing
where not like a China election it'll no
it'll like a China election or North
Korea election where everyone kind of
rolls their eyes like yo this is not an
election they all line up to vote but
it's I don't think either of them can
win that vote because if there's a fake
looking election malice will say well
there was an election I mean again but
both sides whenever side loses will
claim that there was some sort of funny
business right between Mouse and
Roseanne the the point is that they're
having fun ribbing on each other I think
they're going to have to go someone's
going to pay Creator clash it's going to
be Rosanne and Michael malice boxing to
to decide the final Victor yo but but I
I agree because I I've been saying this
for some time now and shout out to Dave
Smith when he was here he brought up he
said to me that the the best thing I
mentioned on the podcast with Jack dorsy
was that I said if they kept doing this
it would lead this country to Civil War
and they all laugh cuz like are you nuts
like what are you talking about and then
January 6th and then the summer of love
and now we're at the point where 2 the
reason why I said this back then 2016
nobody believed actually happened like
the Democrats think Donald Trump was a
Russian SP and they maybe have walked
back now now that not all of them right
but for years they were like Trump is
working for the Soviets they only walked
it back enough so that way someone if
someone challenges them on it now
they'll well maybe not blah blah but as
soon as That Someone's like no yeah
definitely they'll jump right in there
and be like oh yeah he totally was too
now now you've got Republicans saying
Biden didn't win so 2024 like you said
no one will accept the results yeah so I
think Michael's going to lose this one
because no matter what happens no one
there's not going to be a functional
resolution to the election so it may be
that Rosanne meant to say nobody will
vote it may be that she meant to say
Trump will be removed it'll be a sham
election or the reality is we'll all go
and vote and then the results will be
challenged so we'll never actually have
a winner in which case Roseanne will win
and Michael's going to have to pay up
I'm really concerned about the the
voting machines man that that all our
votes can go into some digital database
and get flip-flopped around and then fed
back to us like I I I'm with you I think
that in 2024 this election is going to
be contested for whatever reason and
going to be unresolved for a lot of
people so we've got to start developing
a way to live accepting that that's
reality that it's been the reality for
the last two elections but this is
different 2016 Democrats did challenge
the vote they they they filed lawsuits
they launched campaigns they lied they
produced fake information they
fabricated evidence 2020 Donald Trump
and and and his supporters launch waves
of lawsuits Trump's team wins a large I
think they won the majority of their
lawsuits filed But ultimately didn't get
remedy because the determination was the
amount of votes challenge didn't
wouldn't have resulted in a change in
the election the media is lying in
claiming that they were thrown out and
he lost all them that's not true what's
going to happen in
2024 I imagine we're going to get to the
point where no one's going to no one's
going to that you're going to get
different reports on which state went to
who you're going it's going to end up in
uh at the electoral vote count it's
going to be what what the Democrats
claim was going to be they're not going
to be able to to to to call this
properly they're going to vote it's
going to be contested and there's going
to be no clear winner that that is the
lightest prediction because what may
happen between the election day in
November and Inauguration Day in in
January and then you've got like the
vote count in December whatever it's
going to be I I have to imagine every
single organization in the country will
file a lawsuit yeah I don't see how we I
it's with 2020 with 2016 you have to
imagine that that right now every
Democrat lawyer and every Republican
lawyer is sitting down saying they're
they're probably already drafting their
arguments oh easily the the the votes
have not even happened yet and they're
drafting up a bunch of arguments for
standing for grounds all of this stuff
it's going to be the day after the
election and you're going to see a wave
of losses F in fact I'm pretty sure this
happened in
2016 vaguely remember when they called
Nevada for Hillary the Trump team
announced a lawsuit was being filed
against them already and then Trump
ended up winning so like nothing with
that but I could be wrong but something
like that happened yeah I mean if Trump
wins a lot of people's heads are going
to explode in this country Trump can't
win in the sense that the media will
claim he didn't lawyers will file
lawsuits and they'll make up a reason as
to why he didn't really win even when he
does yeah I mean because that was 2016
yeah I don't imagine that's going to be
the problem I think that I still think
that the the um ballot harvesting and
stuff is going to be the actual thing
that that solidifies the Democrats
winning I I think that it's that in the
lock as of right now I I I disagree
while I do think ballot harvesting plays
a big role Republicans have been picking
up on this narrative people like Scott
Pressler have been picking up on this
but more importantly the new poll from
NBC showing 18 to 34 four yearolds are
now
Republican I I don't look man you get a
couple of democrat activists to go knock
on the door in New York which is a Biden
plus 10 and a d plus 27 that 30-year-old
is going to knock on the door a
30-year-old dude's going to answer and
they're going to be like hey you get
your mail and vote how would you like to
vote for Joe Biden is going to go is
that a joke yeah get out of my face I
guess it's possible it won't be Joe
Biden though exact but hold on even
Gavin Nome will not allow a democratic
recovery enough to be Trump but my fear
and I do not like living in fear but
this is just like I'm staring at the
mouth of the Beast is the electronic
voting machines that they will take all
the votes they'll be like thank you
everyone for your participation Gavin
Newsome 15149 doesn't matter just like
in 2000 when George Bush went 20 5149
and what did did Biden beat Trump 50
50.5 none of this matters but you're
you're you're thinking in terms of 2020
and 2016 2024 is going to be every
lawyer in the country filing a lawsuit
all at the same time over every day for
the for several weeks and every Court
will be jammed up and everyone's going
to say we have no idea attack on the
government voting process or or it's a a
a a legal Riot is there anything that
done to mitigate this happening
considering like probably you know we're
not the only people who are talking
about this right now you could have like
seven blockchains set up to verify the
vote I don't think that's they're going
to have that in place by otherwise we
could sit around with our fingers up our
but first everyone everyone needs to
vote everyone needs to get their friends
and family to vote everybody needs to
reach out to Scott presler and say what
can I do to help but the issue is not
voting right now the issue is law fair
that's that's the point Trump could win
80% and they'll argue clearly the
machines are broken Trump could not have
won by this much and this proves the
discrepancy and the election must beone
and you'll get thousands of re uh
lawsuits and the courts will start going
through that could be a foreign attempt
to St sty our elections is by inciting
us to create too many lawsuits on
ourself
yeah it's it's not for no no no that
that that that that's impossible it's
for sure it's like a terroristic they've
got us to fear our own system the issue
is not that Russia created BLM ad and
encouraged black lives matter to make
the rightwing angry the issue is that
Democrats have already stated the the
the leadership of the democratic party
in 2020 that if Trump were to win they
would encourage West West in in their in
their war game they said we would we
would uh push west coast states to
secede from the union unless Trump gave
in and gave them concessions it was John
podesta I think it was podesta and many
others who were involved in that war
game that is not Russia doing it that is
the Democratic party oh gosh she doesn't
need to be a country of foreign when I
say foreign it could be a corporation it
could be people that are manipulating us
to be afraid of each other so that we
Sue each other and and and look let me
tell you I mean it's been done the last
few times going happen
again I I I think this this this path is
inevitable I don't think we lose I think
clearly we're seeing the worldview that
we share is is is much larger a bigger
umbrella and is more likely to win but I
was talking to a friend the other day
who told me outright someone I've know
my whole life that baby at 9 months even
if it is about to be born is a parasite
on the mother and the mother has a right
to turn to end it alive not a parasite
it's a symbiote but I'm I'm I'm not I'm
not speaking to facts I'm saying this is
what the my friend said to me and I said
whatever you think understand that
position is fringe and is going to
result in serious conflict in this
country because Colorado allows that and
Oklahoma doesn't but when I heard
someone outright say I will Never Back
Down babies gested to 9 months are a
parasite within the mother and the
mother can can can remove it if she
wants even if it ends the life because
that's not even a baby it's not even
alive it's a fetus and I'm like if the
only thing separating two babies is a
layer of Flesh from the mother and the
other baby was born but they're the
identical in every other way nope
parasite and I said okay that's pretty
that's uh I think Super thankfully I
think that's super Fringe but that is
still however those are the laws being
passed yeah I understand that which is
why I actually think we're going to win
because that is super Fringe and no one
is like the average person is going to
be like why you nuts yeah that's crazy
but here's what I realize it's really
easy guys you want to know why it is the
life doesn't care about books in schools
cuz I had this conversation with a
friend and she was saying like I don't
hear anything about this and I'm like
right you don't have kids yeah you don't
have kids in school all my friends who
have
kids freaking out they're all like you
should see the stuff that my kid learns
and like basically they have to depro
deprogram their kids when their kids
come home like their kids come home and
they say all the stuff and then they
going be like yeah that's not really
true we were talking about Lowden County
and I'm like why is why is Virginia you
know why did Virginia elect a republican
Governor granted they've elected a lot
of Democrats recently but uh why did
Lowden County flip and and bring in a
republican da and I'm like parents are
seeing these books the da arrested a
father who was screaming at people for
covering up the rape of his daughter and
then it's like here's the issue these
liberals don't have children they will
cease to exist in in a couple
Generations that's it and not if they
can't take the whole place down with
them they might but but they're not
going to look 40-year-old Millennial
women who aren't having kids they can
push whatever ideas they want I'll tell
you this uh let me let me do this for
you guys check this out this is uh
Civics do you approve or disapprove of
the way Joe Biden is handling his job as
president there is one demographic one
that approves of Joe Biden can you
figure out what that one demographic
would be cat owners no no no no no no
look at the look at the options you've
got age and you've got education and
you've got gender see that
far any any okay so let's say 18 to 34
year olds do you think they support Joe
Biden no they do not what about 35 to 49
sorry they do not 50 to 64 nope how
about 65 plus still no still no still no
uh okay Highly Educated postgraduates
nope they disapprove who likes them then
post graduate women ah is the only
demographic that supports Joe Biden okay
I I I I'm I'm being hyperbolic because
I'm not including race or or state from
this I'm saying out of Education gender
party and age obviously if you go to
Democrats you're going to find much
higher approval substantially the
Democratic party clearly does but in
terms of non-party affiliation out of
age and education and gender only
post-graduate females have a approval
rate a high approval rating a higher
appr approval rating for Joe Biden when
did that start ticking down uh it was is
that in the last month it was uh uh it
was Hamas attack on Israel yeah is it
literally cuz you know what it is so
funny because these are like you see all
the post the videos of posters getting
torn down like the it's all women pretty
much y they're and then now they're all
like Biden's turning our his back on us
childless Highly Educated women hold
these Fringe views they're not having
kids I just think the future is
predictable they're not having kids and
the ideas are going to go with them when
they go yeah they're going to be a
fringe group making demands on young
people who are going to be like what
world do you live in you like weird
communist old
woman yeah I I have to agree with you on
that one they're going to get more
cats I will say before toosa before we
go to super chats uh we have a new cat
we uh I mentioned this the other day we
captured Sheamus and uh in a cage and uh
uh we brought him to the vet and he got
uh cleaned up deep parasites and all
that stuff I'm not talking about Sheamus
2 talking about Sheamus one Sheamus 2 is
the cartoonist Sheamus 1 is the cat is
the cat yeah yeah but appar uh so he was
living in a garage cuz he found a way in
and uh so we set up a trap we we caught
him based on how he looked I I I figured
he was probably like eight months old
cuz cats get they they grow pretty quick
and I was correct he is uh 8 to 10 or so
months and uh uh he's a good little dude
he's uh we broke his Spirit he was
screaming when he got caught I have to
like come on it's probably pretty
frightening well no it's just like his
honor you know oh he's an honorable cat
no it's like we it was the indignity of
having him in a trap and laughing at him
you know we like pointing our fingers
and laughing what entails trapping a cat
like a raccoon trap well there there
small animal traps yeah yeah and the way
it works is there's like a a metal plate
and when the cat walks in it steps on a
plate which pulls a piece of metal and
Clos behind goes down nice and then he
can't get out and then we uh we got him
cleaned up the good news is he's very
nice nice his spirit's been broken and
we've pet him and given him uh many
cookies and he is uh shout out Sheamus
one he looks pretty depressed but uh he
is now property of me nice and and and
that's it I have dominion over him that
he will survive the winter he will
survive any Winters I mean yeah he's
he's he's about 8 to 10 months old so
he's not he was born likely around
probably last spring and so we I I was
like this he's he's not going to survive
living out here in the middle and like
with nothing so but now uh now he'll
make it sorry we're going to go to super
chats if you haven't already would you
kindly smash that like button subscribe
to this channel share the show with your
friends head over to Tim cast.com click
join us become a member to uh support
our cultural Endeavors to watch the
members only uncensored show that will
be coming up in about a half an hour and
to hang out in the in the Discord server
with like-minded individuals we got a
bunch of awesome documentaries you
definitely got to check out infringed by
Lauren Southern and John DUIs it's
awesome but uh let's let's read your
super chats right now now Josh Berg says
Hey guys first today I'm looking to
build a warden Cliff tower on a micr
scale something interesting to look up
if you don't know what it is Ian what is
that that's Tesla's Tower Nicola Tesla
built that Tower and he called it Warden
cliff and it was a giant um long range
electricity Wireless energ trans
wireless electricity generator
apparently or not generator but
transmitter transmitter yeah I so I
wonder if like the main issue with that
is that it kills people cuz I have to
imagine if you're like transporting high
levels of energy wirelessly you're
losing a ton of energy and probably
creating some kind of
disruptive you know I don't know
radioactive pulse of some sort yeah I
think was he trying to send it
underground or something through the
Earth maybe well I think we've all seen
uh The Prestige right yes that scene
where he has the light bulbs in the
ground and they turn on oh Warden C was
that that was the prestige right yeah
with Hugh Jackman that mov was awesome
it what was the other one that was kind
of like that cuz they always make two
movies that are the
same there's like two movies each about
magicians doing tricks I don't know the
Catch Me If You Can was that the one me
if
you it's a movie like that's where thebe
I'm think of The Prestige it's with the
guy from Facebook movie The Met movie I
I don't know with uh what's his name all
I know is the prestig The Illusionist
Illusionist yep see they knew chat
always has the answers well I I will ask
the audience mind where we at Matthew
Hammond says have Danny and Ryan long
written a script for a movie yeah we
have you two are this generation's Dan
arroy and John balushi and it is a shame
if we did not see something on the
screen well where's it at what you doing
with it uh we wrote a script um like two
years ago and then uh this basically uh
but it's it's it's done for essentially
it was very of the
times and uh it just like we we we tried
to basically rewrite it and like for to
update it as essentially and it just it
was very much of that moment uh like
probably a few years ago too many co
jokes no there was no there was no Co
references whatsoever actually but like
part of it involved uh Twitter it was a
whole thing but and like like like it
was basically this like bloggers movie
making fun of like left wi right-wing
bloggers essentially I was like played a
Ben Shiro type and Ryan was like played
like the head of Vice kind of thing and
then but Vice is bankrupt it's like all
this it's like the world has changed so
fast and like there was like a whole
Twitter angle to and it's just like
Twitter different com now it's just it's
too different but but we're always
thinking of ideas the problem is we're
just nobody wants to make them how much
money do you to make one million dollars
let's do it all right write me a script
dude we got we got lots of good ideas
let's let's get it let's do we'll make a
movie yeah man all right there we go uh
that that's that that constitutes a
contract also it means Ryan long is now
contractually obligated as well I can't
see I I don't speak for Ryan long but
but we we talk about movies all the time
cuz that's like that like when I got
into comedy and stuff like I wanted to
make movies like I've written many
scripts like that's what I've written a
movie called philth City you can check
it out it's about it's on tub it's about
the crack smoking mayor former mayor of
Toronto Rob Ford Rob for yeah Rob Ford
is it's called Phil City you can check
it out so and I like I started it and
wrote it so I'm serious uh I think
Ryan's going to be here next week next
week yeah I was going to come with him
but then I was supposed to be in
Edmonton and then I'm not now but so so
come with him you want me to come with
him again yeah maybe I think I might
yeah maybe uh and then we'll talk about
making a movie yeah and uh you know
we'll have we'll have Ian play a
scientists who invents a graphine
gun it's going to happen oh yeah you're
definitely going to get impaled at some
point in it's looking through the hole
in we should the hair like shooting out
we're going looking through the hole
being like this is
[Applause]
bad so they already made a graphine
horror movie It's called Splinter oh
have you should look it up no I haven't
heard of it it's a graphine horror movie
yeah look it up I want to see uh look up
Splinter horror movie from 2008 I don't
know trapped in an isolated gas station
still barely know what gra yeah that's
2008 yeah that's a long time ago wow I
didn't realize it was so old yeah look
at the pictures look at the pictures of
this station go to images you're going
to be like oh wow do you see the
pictures oh yeah the stuff shooting out
of his body looks like ferof fluid right
ferof yeah like graphine pherom magnetic
graphine turns people into monsters
that's see Ian is an agent of chaos I
know he's the only person I've ever know
who even references it let's grab some
more Super chats love it so much Shane H
Wilder says for my birthday I'm asking
if people are able to please give to my
Parish a sprinkler busted and flooded
the Nave it is St Albert in the dicese
of Austin it is also Joe Biden's
birthday so instead of giving Joe
anything help this guys uh
perish okay here we go Jacob paridis
says congratulations Javier mle Trump is
next
absolutely let's grab some more Lord
Lucas says did you see that Iceland is
going Ragnarok no what does that mean uh
Ragnarok is like the is the apocalypse
of like the the Norse mythology but why
Iceland what's going on in Iceland a
city split in half and it's about to a
volcano about to erupt saw that's pretty
cool PR except for them except for them
a bunch of volcanoes at once erupted did
you guys hear about that last week at
the end of last week they were saying
like really seven volcanoes were were
activating at once seven volcanoes yeah
but I don't I don't want to get the
numbers wrong seven trumpets and I don't
know if it could be confirmed that it
was actual activity or not there well
there were there there's
at any given time there's like 20
different volcanoes erupting on Earth so
it's it was seven that were going at the
same time but it's not like it's super
odd there's constantly volcanic activity
on planet Earth and it it just happened
no I I think you're wrong I think
clearly the volcanoes erupting are the
seven trumpets of the Revel of
Revelation and uh signaling the uh end
of days this is all from my potential
fake news of I'm ready for end of days
there's approximately 1350 potentially
active volcanoes yeah there's yeah there
there's like maps you can watch online
of volcano just going off it's you know
everyone's always just very worried
about uh what is it Yos see
yeah that's the big one it's Yellowstone
right yeah I think so yell or yeah
that's the one where that's that's just
kind of the country exploding though
like that's just like no sun for two
years yeah it's it's like the S the size
of the super volcano it's basically just
like the whole Northwest of the United
States blows up and it's D right yeah
something like it's like it's like the
does whatever it's couple hundred
thousand years due I think something
like that sick yeah if that pops off
though no one will even know what
happened yeah I mean we might over here
for a minute for a little bit not too
long we'll be informed when when flaming
rocks start landing around us yeah true
what do we have redneck Italian says
your members are always generous
generous I'd figured I'd ask him to help
my son achieve his baseball dreams this
Christmas consider donating at giv Ando
Douglas Jr showcase couldn't put the
link in well I guess it depends on
donating for what you know some people
are like my mother is dying or my dog is
sick so uh you know make it worth it
nothing more American than a baseball
dream yeah carinal nature says X would
not allow me to subscribe to Premium
Plus tonight and stating that it is due
to me changing my profile photo or
screen name within the last three days
I've been on acc since 2014 what gives
errors uh I'll say this too like we we
launched an ad campaign for infringed it
says it's delivered but there's like
some issue with yeah they they have some
bugs I mean like think about how much
has changed since he took over they for
all the time I was on Twitter they
didn't do anything nothing changed it
was just the same and then all of a
sudden he comes in he's like here's 50
new things so yeah yeah Fair Point all
right where we at let's grab another
Super
chats DS says Timmy longtime listener
first- time super chatter first off love
what you're doing brother keep with the
great work second I had to unsubscribe
from the monthly mix only to subscribe
directly to appalachin nights blessings
uh well I appreciate it I that's my
favorite well it's tough I think appal
night is probably my favorite I just
it's insane how good it is it's the
coffee by the way the cas coffee yeah uh
Danny you're not drinking enough I I'm
not however much Casper you're drinking
it's not enough you drink more yeah yeah
okay okay all right and and that'll be
the uh uh the movie deal okay you don't
got to put it in the movie some product
plac none of that none of that you just
have to drink a couple glasses okay you
got some here you send me home some and
and not on camera or anything I you just
have to just have some okay there there
you go and then we'll the movie there we
go that that's that's how we doe that's
how we do the deals and then all Danny
wants to drink the coffee Danny likes to
drink it too he just he drank it one
time and then forever I can say that and
it's worth wor more than an aded don't a
a drinker a drinker through coffee let's
see uh ply P says I was a tourist in the
Soviet Union in 1991 no homes had
electricity nobody owned a car except
the government officials all dirt roads
except for a major city A Primitive dump
the best part hot water is
centralized when you in Ukraine in Kev
uh well I don't know if this is true
anymore because I'm not sure what's left
of KV it's probably mostly fine let's be
real but um the hot water in your
apartment never runs out yeah because
the way they the way they it's from the
uh Power Plant yeah so the hot water
yeah the hot water that's used to create
steam to spin the turbine at the coal
plant is recycled through pipes into
people's homes yeah that's kind of cool
yeah I think it's clean I don't know
I'll tell you the one story that my
parents always tell me is when they were
kids in the Soviet Union whenever you
saw a line you just got in it cuz you
just knew it was something you
wanted wow always my mom always said
when she was a little girl if there was
a line she goes I got in the line and
you just waited cuz whatever it was you
knew you wanted it so I have this Theory
I was in uh I was flying from London to
Kev with a stop in Moscow and uh in the
United States when you're boarding a
plane they say no boarding in group one
and then group one walks up now boarding
group two and group two walks up
sometimes someone from group three comes
in and then they're like sir is this
group three or they'll just be like Oh
I'm you know let let me in but typically
everyone waits in Moscow they were like
now boarding group one every single
person stormed the gate and they were
shoving each other out out of the way
and waving their tickets at the at the
gate agent and I'm like I wonder if
that's a remnant of the Soviet era where
if you did not fight for food you died
yeah for sure like yeah you just yeah a
culture evolved where everyone said I'm
going to shove my way to the front or
I'm not going to make it because during
the worst elements of the Soviet Union
the families that said no no we'll wait
our turn yeah died every bread line was
just January 6th all over again yeah you
see lot that in China as well now a lot
of Chinese people are like they're like
oh why they have no like no uh manners
whatever like that CU if you had manners
you're going to die you're have food
it's just like a yeah yeah it's just
natural it's natural
reaction Venus Sophia says the only
subscriptions I pay for our a and
timcast well I really do appreciate it
there we go gyro Murphy says a few weeks
ago you said you had big plans for
Pittsburgh I run some shops around
Pittsburgh and I would like to talk with
you about how to bring some solid
culture to my city what's the best way
to get in touch with you um I don't know
I think it's to be completely honest
it's like impossible uh I don't I
basically don't have email I basically
don't have a phone number because it's
impossible for me to actually use and
then I have like staff at timcast who
take care of everything else it's just
it's no like seriously it becomes
impossible you know you you get you get
a phone number and then one person will
figure out a one way to get your number
and they'll share with everybody it is
the downside of being famous it's like
I'm I find myself standing on the
precipice of being famous and like God I
still like to check my Twitter
notifications because I enjoy like
hearing what people think and it gets to
a point where it's impossible the noise
the feedback becomes so great the amount
of phone calls you get in the day you
got to shut your phone off it's already
on silent like man it is it is a it is a
type of sacrifice but the the benefit is
so great to be well known in society
could graphine solve
this I don't know I don't know maybe a
graphy neural net I don't know but that'
be a whole other problem still don't
even really know what it is nope uh yeah
I basically just I don't have email you
don't have email at all I've not no
there there's the only way to get in
touch with me is if you know someone who
knows me slack and uh corporate
corporate chat rooms or if they can take
over that phone of yours uh Twitter your
girl has follow you on Twitter you can
message me or if you uh know someone who
works here okay then someone walks up to
me and says oh hey Tim I talk to someone
who says this and I'll like oh okay
great let's let's you know follow
through but that's about it yeah it's a
good filtering system but we do have big
plans for Pittsburgh they're currently
in in in the works we are like 50%
towards our uh setup goal for in terms
of like organizational and it's going to
be tremendous so we're really really
excited for this and we've got some big
plans for December this I will say now
because I want people to get ready for
this and the event it does happen we are
working on a December 11th event in New
Hampshire and uh we're we're we're it's
it's it's probably going to happen so
it's going to be on will mely will if we
do it I believe we're looking at like
December 11th live timcast IRL I know
it's a Monday but it'll be big it'll be
special it'll be fun and uh there's a
chance it doesn't happen because of the
logistics but uh you know some other
stuff and then there's like other stuff
working on for the uh for the month of
December before we wrap up the last week
of December after like Christmas week
we're not here because uh I hate not
working but it's just it's impossible no
one watches it's it's not that it's
nobody will come yeah right right the
Live Events so so you know no it's IRL
we can't book guests like literally no
human being is like I I sure I'd love to
fly halfway across the country to come
to your studio just after Christmas I
mean I'll come I'm in New York and I'm
Jewish but um well there you go
it's Third Day Hanukkah is the 11th uh
the 11th I'm talking about after
Christmas so basically doing stand up in
New York after Christmas to New Year's
yeah you've got the the the the the few
days after Christmas ain't nobody's
gonna nobody wants to come and then uh
the weekend we don't do take the week
off so that's what we're doing yeah just
take the week that's what we're doing
because it's just like otherwise work
hard enough
yeah all right where we at let's grab
some more Super
chats Mike Burger says love what you're
doing with skate how can I align my
newish brand spirit of fear with what
you've got planned I want to support and
participate I don't know um right now
we're working on the boonies the new
show I just we pre-recorded a podcast
with Richie Jackson Taylor Silverman and
uh Dennis willerford this is uh going to
go up Friday for uh uh on Black Friday
culture war on tenet media and uh
basically it was you know we're we're
we're skating all the time Richie
Jackson is a very very prominent pro
skater he's a super rad dude he's not a
very political guy and uh I think so
many pro athletes want to just say like
dude I don't know or care about this
politics stuff man I just I skate or I
play ball or whatever and there are
people who want to force politics into
it so I'm just like we're going to do
our thing but we talked quite a bit
about it and the thing about
skateboarding is that I never used to
film I hate I hate filming skateboarding
I filmed some things if you if you
search on YouTube for like me
skateboarding you might find some really
old videos there's videos of me skating
when I was 16 that are up on YouTube I
actually uh my friend Brett Novak filmed
one of the oldest YouTube videos in
existence Tim pool skating at a Chicago
Warehouse it has like a million views or
or half a million views or something
like that however recently I started
filming a lot and the reason is I want
to destroy wokeness and woke people have
started infecting skateboarding with
their woke garbage oh really I look man
I said this years ago it came for video
games it came for movies it came for
Comics it will come for Major League
Sports it's only a matter of time before
someone's like well the rules are
arbitrary we can make it so women have
to play with the men and the NBA has to
have women that's inevitable if this
persists if we win however we can keep
playing basketball and just say May the
best person get on the team but
skateboarding got to the point where I'm
like hanging out and I see a magazine
nobody really reads magazine anymore
like oh I pop it open and there's an
advertisement for a brand and it's a
skatebo it's it's I'm not saying not a
trans person a guy in a dress not a
trans person okay I want to make sure
this is clear there a guy wearing a
dress and I'm like okay well you know
punk rock whatever be shocking I don't
really care I turn the page and there's
an advertisement for a brand and the
skateboarder is not doing a trick and
I'm like okay well you know sometimes
they have these I guess then I see what
the last draw was an
advertisement that was a Slappy okay
anybody who knows skateboarding knows a
slap what Slappy means you just rode the
board up a curb and off a curb yeah so
it's like imagine an ad where it's like
we have the best athletes and it shows
LeBron James is doing like speed walking
right you'd be like huh like come on
this dude can dunk I want to see a 360
dunk like now don't get me wrong
sometimes ads are just the athlete
endorsing something by doing nothing but
it really did start getting to the point
where skateboarding started embracing
funding and propping up skateboarders
who do not know how to skate why
identity and so I'm like okay it's time
to to put an end to this we are going to
fund to a very very large sum of money
skateboard media culture that pushes
back against this don't get me wrong
most of the big media brand stuff is
still doing the good skateboarding with
the good tricks and I totally respect it
but seeing these people and it has a lot
to do with them attacking companies so
when I hear from my friend who's a pro
skater and he's like we're getting
attacked by these woke people for not
doing X I'm like okay I'm going to put
money in this and I'm going to destroy
that that's not going to get anywhere at
no ground in skateboarding so now on
Instagram I've got a bunch of skate
clips that are that are going up just
this uh just yesterday I landed what's
called a switch El Nino nice yeah it's a
sounds hard it is it is it's a very
difficult trick it is a switch front
side 360 and a kick flip allinone nice
so the board and my body spin around 360
Degrees while the board flips underneath
me and did it on a bank and it was a
very it was very fun and it's a
difficult trick and then I also have
what's called A hang1 Hard flip light
flip which is a trick that only I have
probably ever done it is maximum
difficulty there's there is not you
invented it probably well it's it's it's
a combination move it combines a hang1
hard flip and a late flip oh gotcha so
the way I do the hang1 hard flip may be
unique to me it's hard to claim you
invented things but this is called NBD
never been done nice and so it there is
there is quite literally in terms of
degrees of difficulty this is the
highest possible degree of difficulty
for trick the videos on my Instagram why
um we are going to start trying to
inspire people and build culture so now
I'm actually we're actually filming nice
and we're going to bring bring Pros out
we're going to film with them we already
brought out some AMS and filmed to them
and we're just going to be like dude
we're we're reclaiming the space and
we're like we're kicking you out is
Scott Horton a good skateboarder Yes
actually yeah that you that episode on
Friday was incredible Scott is he's an
old man sorry Scott uh but he actually
this is crazy okay look he keep the suit
on no he changed when we go to the mini
ramp I'm like let me do my stretches let
me warm up I'm doing kick turns I'm
doing some rock to fakies he just throws
his board down and goes right for the
six foot section and he's like oh it
feels better and I'm like you're 10
years older them you're not warming up
and you're throwing down in the six foot
already like he's good yeah he's old
school skater
but uh he actually has pretty good kick
flips so uh I don't think he skates as
often he does a lot of work these days
but he's good the first time he came
here he it was like midnight he's like
we got to skate and I'm like bro I can't
skate at midnight and actually I did a
kickflip pivot on the mini ramp so it
was a good day good day skating with
Scott yo he that show with him and wheel
chamber awesome yeah I listen to that on
the train today thought dude just
awesome knowledge drop yeah yeah wow
well check it out uh tenant media on
YouTube that's the new home for the
culture War it's basically our uh
culture War super group Benny Johnson
Dave Rubin Taylor Hansen laurren
Southern me we are basically like you
know making a super group so it's really
cool Taylor Hansen's got an awesome
video where he goes to people and he
asks them do you think we should ban
books in schools and they're like no and
then he goes okay read this and it's one
of the you know one of the books they
ban and they're like ah no we should ban
that he's like okay here we go so super
cool all right we'll read a few more
Mike Ro uh Ric says I'm very proud to
say I voted I I have voted for Ken
Paxton every time he's on the ballot I
knew he was going to beat that shame
impeachment trial sham impeachment trial
I plan to vote for him again and again
love the
show yeah I've talked to people about it
they say it's total BS so glad glad he
won oh yeah he's doing good
work let's go barely Millennial says we
really do have a great capacity for
success and greatness if we just apply
ourselves eventually the Army will be
Mighty thank you for all you do thank
you guys for watching for real we are uh
we're investing probably close to a
million dollars in
one of the best skate facilities that
will exist it's going to it's going to
be on the east coast and it's going to
uh people are going to wish they could
be there the barracks is the one of the
most prominent media entities in
skateboarding I'm a huge fan the the
guys at the bars are awesome people glad
to see them do their thing we are going
to have our own facility on the East
Coast that does things that are
relatively similar but it's not just
skateboarding it's going to be Action
Sports and uh look man you want to come
skate in your lgbtqia whatever we do not
care that is not what it's about where
is it West Virginia oh West Virginia
yeah yeah so like an hour from DC hour
and a half from DC but uh uh you know
it's it's it's private it's going to be
like 90% private but my point is the one
thing we don't tolerate intolerance so
the people who are like you're not
allowed to skate here because you're a
big BL BL actually that's you and I
don't care if a Dude shows up you can
wear whatever he wants he can skate so
that's the other thing too and have fun
yeah like the politics out of it so this
is what's what's happening in the area
there this is a big thing happened there
were uh uh skateboarders at a spot they
did not own they threatened to
physically remove me if I showed up and
I was like skateboarders trespass all
the time to skate and there's this
makeshift Park on someone else's
property and they actually publicly
stated if I shut up they would
physically remove me and I was like okay
well I bought it it's mine now but we
were we were trying to buy it in the
first place cuz we didn't think there
was any beef and it was crazy that we're
Martinsburg like we're buying property
we're building a skat Park we're doing
these things and then after that they
post we will physically remove him if he
shows up I'm like that's going to be
awkward cuz I own that property that's
weird cuz you're all banned but I'm not
Banning anybody yeah I'm like dude you
guys aren't allowed to kick
skateboarders out yeah now look if if
someone's going there and they're
smashing things and they're doing drugs
and they're doing illegal stuff no no no
that's not a skateboarder yeah but if
some skateboarder says they want to
skate and you're like no it's ours dude
now you get out what are they checking
IDs at the park that it's just crazy I I
was I I thought it was hilarious when
they were like if Tim pool shows up
where we're moving them I'm like oof
this is going to be weird physically
assault you I don't know but I was
talking to some dude from the park and
I'm like I told him like two weeks later
I was like hey want let you know I own
this yeah and like we bought it and he
was like what you stole you're buying it
from under us I was like bro he said why
didn't you tell us when this was going
down that you were buying it and I'm
like because you were screaming in my
face and threatening me with physical
Force I I like that he that he says
buying this out from under us as if they
were going to purchase it like like will
you just he out bid you like just snuck
in there and and and bought it out from
under you no you were never going to buy
it homie and then what they did was they
started telling everybody that I bought
it so I could destroy
it like these people are evil dude yeah
they were like oh no we we tried Banning
some R like a skateboarder from a park
and now once we find out that he's
actually the legal owner of it now we're
just going to claim he's going to
destroy it you have to hate him and I'm
like not only will I not destroy it we
will legally protect it and we will
expand it in any way you guys want the
only the only the only constraint is
like dude you can't tell someone because
of something totally unrelated to
skateboarding and non-criminal because
of their worldviews or who they are they
can't skateboard yeah these people are
bigots you should hire 20 body doubles
who can also skateboard and then all
dress the same and then show up all
together that' be a good
video because then they don't know who
to kick out would you like to manage
this project uh I I could I could run a
casting session with you if you want if
I would not do it but if well you just
put out a casting call literally Tim
pool M Tim pool look alike must be able
to skate send in your head shots and
they just have to look like you similar
body has to skate un you all get the
exact same wardrobe and you just all
show up at the same skate park with all
these people there and then they're like
is it him you know that's a really good
idea we should we should do this at
Freedom Plaza in DC and just get like
we'll get like a hundred guys
yeah all all right man if you haven't
already would you kindly smash that like
button subscribe to this channel share
the show with your friends head over to
timcast.net
Danny jokes I don't have Instagram
anymore I technically do Danny jokes 2.0
new episodes of the boyscast with the
homie Ryan long who is going to be here
very soon uh every Friday and tomorrow
night on my YouTube channel low value
mail Ma
I uh the best Callin radio show on the
internet we have all sorts of uh great
guests I had Megan Murphy last week I
got Mark Dice tomorrow night open phone
lines you can call in talk to the guests
uh go follow that YouTube page please
what time does that show go live starts
9:00 P P.M every Tuesday night I should
have mentioned that 9:00 P p.m Eastern
every Tuesday night and we have all
sorts of great guests all the time I am
Phil that remains on Twix I'm Phil that
remains official on Instagram the band
is All That Remains you can follow us on
Twitter and or you can follow us on
Pandora and Spotify and YouTube music
and Amazon music you know the internet
I'm Ian Crossland follow me at Ian
Crossland subscribe to me on YouTube M's
what else we got Instagram uh X and
Rumble and I will show you at 1M
actually tomorrow 1: p.m. Eastern
Standard time I'll be going live so
follow me there and subscribe also for
people that are wondering I was drinking
this Lion's man extract it's a type of
mushroom supplement it's quite good see
you later all right and uh I am
surge.com I enjoyed being on the Discord
I don't know when I'll do that again but
cheers to everyone that was there to
talk to me over the weekend on Saturday
um yeah like I said we'll see when I get
back on it it was nice talking to you
guys if I told you to speak to me I talk
to some told some people to hit me up on
Twix still again at surge.com cheers
we'll see you all over at timcast.net